Learner B1: هلو الغبار
Learner B1: يا رب العين
Learner B1: هو لما الميتينج بيجي عندكو بتفتحوا الجيميل وتشوفوا
Learner B1: طب متأكدي كده إن ما فيش حاجة في الجنين
Learner B1: شوفي الجمال هتلاقي مبعوت تاني أعتقد يعني شوفي بس إفهم ممكن
Learner B1: انتو جربتوا تدخلوا دلوقتي يعني.
Learner B5: وصل أوص.
Learner B1: تمام تمام
Learner B1: فيها 6 درجات ماء
Learner B1: طب حضرت الأسئلة أو أي حاجة.
Learner B5: ما حضرت شوية بس مش عارفة بقى ينفع ولا لأ.
Learner B1: عظيم جدا. جدا. عظيم جدا جدا.
Learner B3: وأنا كنت في الغروب التاني بس اتنقلت للكروتة بالغلط عملت التذكر الثاني من كل الدنيا
Learner B1: أهلا وسهلا بك ازاي.
Learner B3: أهلا بك إلى غوار.
Learner B1: الحمد لله.
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي سؤال هو انتو شغالين على داتا معينة أو إدوك حاجه ولا يعني ماشي نساوي.
Learner B1: للأسف عندنا مشكلة في الزايدة فمشينها منحاول نعمل صرفي منحاول نعمل
Learner B1: ولسه يعني مهندس هتكوني موجوده يعني
Learner B1: ودلوقتي اللي شغالين عليه إن إحنا بنعمل أسئلة و فورم
Learner B1: عشان خاطر ننزلها عشان تبقى حاجة إلزامية يعني كل الناس اللي في انتنشيب يعملوها يعني
Learner B1: وبس دلوقتي مستنيين عشان كلنا نتناقش في الأسئلة
Learner B1: ونشوفها أنا كتبت شوية أسئلة برضه ماوس.
Learner B3: طب هو اللي كان آخر مرة ده هو ده كان
Learner B3: بتعمل كل أسبوع تعرف ولا لأن ده اللي أنا أخدت منه يعني اللي اشتغلت عليه.
Learner B1: أني معلش تاني.
Learner B3: كان في متين رتو كده اللي هو كان في زي بورد وكان.
Learner B1: اللي هو الرتو اللي كان يوم الاتنين صح؟
Learner B3: أم مش فاكرة كان يوم إيه بصراحة.
Learner B1: اللي هو دخله كل تيم وكان معمول على غوغل ميت حتى معمول على.
Learner B3: أيوة.
Learner B1: ده برضه إحنا معنا صورة من الديش بورد
Learner B1: لكان فيه مشاكل والحاجة الكويسة والحاجات الحلوة اللي حصلت واللي هو ريكمنديشن ممكن أبعتهالك.
Learner B3: لا، شكرا عمدت عليه أساسا ده سؤالي بقى هو بتعمل كل أسبوع ولا.
Learner B1: أعتقد هو حصل مرة كده علشان
Learner B1: فيدباك من من الموجودين في الإنترنت.
Learner B1: بس ما حصلش تاني هو مرة كده؟ وخلاص ما كنش في حاجة النهاردة.
Learner B3: خلاص أوكي تمام شكرا.
Learner B1: ما عرفش.
Learner B3: تمام أوكي.
Learner B1: طب وانتي ممكن الأسئلة فين أو لازم.
Learner B3: هو أنا كنت بكتب أسئله بس مش بس يعني كنت في أسئلة كنت عايزاه اسال هل اليوم.
Learner B1: لو كداها ممكن تروح فيها.
Learner B3: أنا لسه لسه بكتبهم يعني
Learner B3: بس دي ملهاش علاقة بالسرفاي أنتو أنا أنا بس عشان ما اعرفش إنتو هو انتو هتعملوا أسئلة لإيه.
Learner B1: يعني نفس فكرة فيدباك ده بس عايزين نتأكد المشكلة أكبر مشكلة إيه المشاكل الموجودة فينا
Learner B1: الهدف دلوقتي إن أنا أجمع كل الأسئلة مع بعض ونعارضها بشكل 1 منشوف إلي تمام وإلا لأ.
Learner B3: هي لو لي علاقة باليوزير أو الفيد باك من يوزير فلا أنا ما كتبت أسئلة لسه يعني
Learner B3: بس أنا كنت عايز أبعتلهم أسئلة زي مثلا أسألهم على نفسهم يعني أو أسألوه عن.
Learner B1: من المسؤولين عن التدريب. قصدك.
Learner B3: لا لا أسأله مثلا اللي فاتت لو كان في أي مثلا فيدباك فات اللي اختلف ده يعني أسئلة زي دي عشان أعرف القصة من أولها فاهم بس أنا فيدباك. أنا لا لسه ما شفت شلون.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B3: مسك.
Learner B1: رمز روين عرفتي أي أسئلة أو حاجة.
Learner B3: ماء لليوتي لسه.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B3: في.
Learner B1: ، زينب زينب ياسر راوند هربتوا أي أسئلة.
Learner B5: أيوا أنا كتبت.
Learner B1: ممكن تبعتيها فرشات أو أي حتة تاني.
Learner B5: ماشي حاضر.
Learner B1: تمام ممكن تبعتيها معلش ممكن برضه تبعتها في الشيك.
Learner B3: بس أنا عندي سؤال هو حتى لو السرفي دي اتبعت مثلا كم بريسنت ممكن يشاركوا يعني.
Learner B1: هو لو هتتبان إحنا طلبنا من المهندس أحمد إن هو يعني هو اللي عملها
Learner B1: علشان تبان إن هي كلنا نشارك فيها.
Learner B3: بس يبقى كل الناس هتشارك او يبقى العدد كبير.
Learner B1: شاء الله دي حاجة يعني محاولة يعني.
Learner B3: انتو جربتوا تسألوا برضه لو في أي فيدباك يقدروا هم يشاروا معانا أو سألنا و.
Learner B1: ما اعتقدش انهم.
Learner B3: ولا مثلا فيدبات أو حاجات بسيطة إن إحنا نقدر نشتغل عليها.
Learner B1: لا، هو أنا الوحيد اللي احنا كنا نتكلم عليه.
Learner B3: أوكي تمام
Learner B3: أنا عندي سؤال للأسئلة دي انتو هتعملوها فأنا عايزة النهارده ولا ولا بكرة ولا إمتى.
Learner B1: المفروض النهارده بس إحنا مستنيين ندى معانا في الجروب. بس أنا مش قادرة أوصلها بعتلها فرشات مش عارف أوصلها
Learner B1: بعتلها حد يعرف يعمل حاجة يا ريت.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B1: سوف يا ندى. عندها ظرف صحي.
Learner B5: هم دول اللي جمعتوا الله.
Learner B1: ليست مشكلة زينب أسئلة.
Learner B3: انت تستنوا هيدا بكرا ولا تبعتوا الأسئلة دي على طول.
Learner B1: ممكن نتناقش و وإيه ونسأل ونبعت الفورمول ندى لما لما كنت تقلنا ممكن تناقش في الاسئلة دلوقتي
Learner B1: برضو ألاقيه رأيكو يعني بسنيها النهارده يعني.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: تمام ماشي
Learner B1: ممكن تلاقي الفايل ممكن نتناقش الأسئلة ولو تمام أو نفس الفكرة.
Learner B3: أوكي أنا حتى ممكن أقول كم سؤال ولو تمام ممكن ابقى ابعتهم برضو.
Learner B1: تمام ممكن. اهو مثلا أنا أعمل شركة على.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B1: تمام
Learner B1: مظاهر الشيس كريم.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: تمام لحظة بس
Learner B1: أوكي مثلا
Learner B1: ال يفترض بتاعوا نعم سهيل فكرة رقم الموال مش حاببها أوي بس يعني أي رأيك فيها بس نحنا نرجع
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B3: بالذات. إنه أصلا أمليكيشن كله على يعني.
Learner B1: بصي
Learner B1: تمام ممكن أنا برضه فكرة الموبايل مش مش الإسم روياني التريك تمام
Learner B1: رأيك بالسؤال ده
Learner B1: 8.
Learner B5: أيوا ده ممتاز.
Learner B7: أيوا حلوة قوي.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: كنت بدي أسأل نسيت الصين.
Learner B1: ثانية واحدة بس آخذ.
Learner B5: تمام.
Learner B1: لحظة واحدة
Learner B1: تمام
Learner B1: رأيكم ، هو.
Learner B3: لو 5 مش حتفرق.
Learner B1: أنا هدفي من السؤال ده برضه يعني بقول أنا بفكر فيه هدفي من السؤال ده إن هو أعرف يعني مثلا لو أول مرة أجرب متوقع اي حاجة كويسة لا يعني عايز أعرف أول مرة أجرب ده نفسي فيدباك
Learner B1: الذي عنده خبرة أو المتوسط أو اللي عنده معرفة بسيطة ده اللي أنا فكرت فيه.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: سحر غلط يعني مش مشكلة.
Learner B7: قميص أريل.
Learner B7: عندي سؤال الأول. ولا الثاني.
Learner B1: اللي هو مستواك.
Learner B7: ايوه حلو جدا. نعمة.
Learner B1: أنا بس عارضوني يا جماعة عيني الفورمي في حاجة غلط يعني.
Learner B7: مفرهدين من يوم الخميس اللي فات تقريبا.
Learner B1: معليش مشاهدينا بنحاول ده.
Learner B7: دلوقتي من 10.
Learner B1: كان تقريبا مريم.
Learner B7: حاسة زي ما حاسه. زي ما قال
Learner B7: هيحس إن هو عايز يديك أحلى حاجة مش حيبقى قوي يمكن غير الصيغة.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B3: بس أنا عندي سؤال يعني حيحس إن هو عايز يدي أحسن حاجة.
Learner B1: ما يطبل.
Learner B7: يعني مثلا أنا دلوقتي لو لو بسألك سؤال وانت عارفة إننا هشوف إجابته وبسألك عني
Learner B7: هو أنا هستولة هتقولي ، هستولة. فاهمة مش حتقوليلي أي تعليق فهماني.
Learner B3: بس أنا حاسة إن هو في ده لا بس في ناس كتير ما كانتش بطبل.
Learner B1: أيوا ناس كتير كنت.
Learner B7: لا.
Learner B3: كان أكثر،
Learner B7: لأ هو لما لما بش مهندس كان معانا علق على الحتة دي كنا عاملين سؤال زيو وقال إنه هو بيكون مش ألطف حاجة، فأنا لما شفت حاجة زي كدا أنا برضه كنت حاسة مش مش عارفة تقييم قوي
Learner B7: فهماني.
Learner B5: خالص بقى عشان ما نحط شحنة
Learner B5: فيدباك وحش وتبقى بوجين فده يبقى في الآخر أحسن يعني.
Learner B1: بص إحنا ممكن نقول السؤال ده عليه جدل مثلا اللي هو كدا كدا مش مهندس احمد.
Learner B3: عشان الرتو كان ما كنش في أسامي بس هنا الناس تحط اساميها فممكن فعلا ده يأثر.
Learner B1: لا الرتو كان فيه أسامي دي الناس كانت داخلة عادي وبتتكلم بالثقة وقفت و.
Learner B3: بس اللي بيدخلوا يكتبوا فيدباك كلام برضه ما كنش مش.
Learner B5: كثير.
Learner B1: طيب تمام ممكن نسيب نجيبوه ونشوف رأي أبو مهندس أحمد ولا إيه.
Learner B3: حاسه حاسه ممكن نخليها من 1 ل 5 برضو عشان حاسة من 1 العشرة كتير هذا رأيكم
Learner B7: زنجر.
Learner B3: يعني مش حسا.
Learner B7: 1 1 بالنسبة لي غير 1 بالنسبة لي، كان 1 بالنسبه لغيرنا فا.
Learner B5: أيوة بالظبط.
Learner B7: فبلاش نحطها ارقام ممكن نحطها مثلا ككلام بالعربي وصف بالعربي مثلا.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: ممكن اشمعك.
Learner B3: ممكن مثلا هو قصدك مثلا تبقى حلو أوي متوسط.
Learner B7: ايوا كلمت العربية دي حاصلة ان هو ممكن 1 بالنسبة له النجمة ده وهو ممكن يكون
Learner B7: ما طلعش مشروعين 3 عشان خد 1 طالما هو استفاد برضو في حتة تانية، كويس جدا
Learner B7: فهي بتباع الأولويات فممكن نحط كلام بالعربي مثلا.
Learner B1: طيب كان بالعربي فرنش طب ممكن أكون عامل سؤال زيو تحت خليني دا دلوقتي.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: دي.
Learner B7: يعني.
Learner B7: سوريا. قضيعتك.
Learner B1: لا، لا، الحقيقة ممكن يكون قولي قولي.
Learner B7: اشتري أثاثك.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: ما نقولش تقييمك دي أصلا إحنا ممكن نقول وافق توقعاتك بنسبة كم في المية من أدي
Learner B1: خلينا السؤال ده يعني في الآخر تمام إيه عشان اعرفه تمام
Learner B1: أول ما دخلت كان إيه إحساسك فاهم الدنيا من البداية أحكيلك اتفاق.
Learner B7: ممكن أسأل سؤال.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: السؤال ده انت شايف إن إنت ممكن تطلع منه بإيه.
Learner B1: طيب لحظة لحظة، أنا كنت قريب.
Learner B7: نعم مثلا يعني.
Learner B1: أنا.
Learner B7: وأنهى.
Learner B1: كرنبو ملاحظة
Learner B1: أيوب لحظة واحدة
Learner B1: بدل ما أفتح حاجتين مع بعض
Learner B1: السؤال ده كان هدفي منو اعرف هو كان فاهم الدنيا من البداية.
Learner B1: لما لما يعني مثلا هو و هو بيدفع كان فاهم إن الدنيا هيبقى كده بالزبط إي آي و ومش بني آدمين وجو كده كان فاهم الجو ده كان فاهم الدنيا من البداية
Learner B1: ولاحتك شوية ولا كنت شوية يفهم ولا كنت جاي في الأول ولحد دلوقتي الدنيا مش واضحة بالنسبالك فهماني.
Learner B5: أيوا بتحدد في يعني دور في الموضوع.
Learner B1: من غير ما أقوله. إن هو من غير ما أقوله إن يعني كنت عايز أعرف هو فاهم الدنيا عارف إن هو سألت وكده ولا لأ أنا لغاية ما فهمش وبرضه مستني تقولهولو
Learner B1: لو عايزين نقول لو صوتي واضح.
Learner B5: أيوا.
Learner B7: هل سنطلعها من السؤال كويسة بس السؤال مش حيوصلك ليها بصراحة ده رأيي مش عارفة توافقي معاه ولا لأ
Learner B7: بس حتى لو لما دخلت التدريب كان احساسك أنا كده بتكلم عن التدريب ما بتكلمش على حتة حتة فيدباك وحد يرد علي
Learner B7: لا بكلمك.
Learner B1: ولا ولا بكلمهم.
Learner B7: إيه.
Learner B1: أنا مش بكلمه على حدة فيدباك.
Learner B7: حمام.
Learner B1: أنا بكلمه على.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B1: لا مش عايز أعرف لا إحنا يعني فكري بسكوب أكبر
Learner B1: إحنا بنفكر إيه هي المشكلة أصلا
Learner B1: يعني في مشكلة أصلا غير الفيد باك ولا يعني لا يمكن شيلي لي دلوقتي
Learner B1: إحنا دلوقتي أول ما دخلت التدريب كان عندك أحداث شوية عشان تفهم كنت إيه في الأول ممكن يعني زي بعض.
Learner B7: طب سؤال طب سؤال إحنا كده مندور على شفنا نتيجة إيه عشان ندور عليها
Learner B7: إحنا بندور نتيجة المشكلة والنتيجة إنت دلوقتي ببالك.
Learner B1: إيه إحنا بندور إن مش كل الناس راضية عن وفي مشكلة.
Learner B1: والمشكلة دي والمشاكل دي ظهرت في المترو
Learner B1: تمام عاوزين نعمل اللي هو إي أكتر مشكلة كانت مقصرة ومثلا خلت الناس تتضايق وممكن تمشي وإيه المشكلة عادي ممكن عايزين نجمع مشاكل أكتر.
Learner B7: يعني المشكلة ما بقتش في الحماسيد.
Learner B1: لا لا ده نفي به دلوقتي لأ.
Learner B7: أما أنا بعمل أما بعمل هنا بعمل في التصكي اللي أنا بروح لي فيه.
Learner B1: ون وتو تمام سيبي مانو من أول.
Learner B7: عاملين فورم.
Learner B1: الفورم دي اللي هو عايزين نجمع إيه المشاكل حاجة مختلفة كده.
Learner B7: أصلا.
Learner B1: ، وعلى أساسها نعمل البروتوتيب اللي هو المطلوب.
Learner B1: انت ما كنتش معانا في الميديا مبارح شنو كدا ماين.
Learner B7: لا كنت موجودة بس لقطت دي في الآخر وبعد كده موبايلي فصل تاني ملقيتش لينك.
Learner B1: لا هو ده قلنا لو كده لو لقينا إن الفكرة يعني كويسة ممكن نمشي بيها وكل 1 يختار مشكلة ويتعامل على أساسها.
Learner B7: بس انت مش شايف إن دي حاجة محتاجة إننا يكون عندنا رؤية اكبر للي هم شغالين عليه
Learner B7: يعني محتاجين بيانات أكتر محتاجين نشوف حاجات أكتر مش مجرد حاجة بيدولنا بمعلومات صغيرة.
Learner B7: أظن ده أكتر حاجة بالتأكيد بالذات خدولك منها.
Learner B1: ما هو إحنا المفروض فلو انت مهندس أحمد مهندس أحمد يوسف
Learner B1: و ندى هي عملته حتى بس ما عرفش هو رضى عليها ولسه أيوه شفتوها.
Learner B7: نعم.
Learner B1: بالظبط تاني حيساعدونا إن هم يعملوا يخلوا هم هم اللي يعملوا بوست مش إحنا علشان يبقى يبان إن هو كل الناس تخش وتعمله قبل كده حيكون عندنا داتا كويسة جدا.
Learner B7: طب ممكن سؤال تاني.
Learner B1: افعل.
Learner B7: هو إحنا كده دلوقتي بندور على مشاكل موجودة جوا البرنت أصلا وبنقيلها حل.
Learner B1: مش جوا برينت جوا.
Learner B7: أيوه قول إنت نفسها.
Learner B7: بلاقيلها حل يعني دلوقتي إحنا مشاكلنا مش في التذكرات أصلا بلاش نحول تزكرات.
Learner B1: أي.
Learner B7: إحنا كده ما بلاش نحل تزكرات طيب ولا
Learner B1: إحنا حنحل التاسكة اللي جاية على أساس الفيدباك ده.
Learner B7: يعني رجعنا لسبرانت ون على فكرة.
Learner B1: مش هتعملي مش هتعملي وتو تمام.
Learner B1: لا إنت حتخشي حتعملي بروتوتيب على حسب المشاكل اللي هتخرج اللي حتلاقي من هنا فهماني.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي عنيف إيه.
Learner B1: اسألك.
Learner B3: دلوقتي إحنا لما كان ألريدي في ناس كتير أجمعوا على بوينتس معينة عندهم مشاكل فيها، فأنا حاسة إن إحنا تبقى الأسئلة الأولانية هي إن إحنا نسألهم أكتر عن المشاكل دي
Learner B3: وحاجة تانية برضه كنت بفكر فيها أو هو كان المنتر قالها يعني إن إحنا أصلا يعني نسأل ليه الحاجة معمولة كده يعني مثلا ناس كتير كانت شايفة أو ناس كانت مداقة إن هو في تو فيرجينسك فقبل ما إحنا نسأل عن عن أكتر عن المشكلة. نسأل سبينس هم ليه عاملين تو فيرجينس
Learner B3: أنا أصلا ما كنتش عارفة إن تو غبس يوم تو فيرجينس أو كده
Learner B3: وبعد كده نسأل ال يوزر إنت إيه مضايقك أصلا في الموضوع ده فنكون واخدين تو سايتس كده يعني فاهمين الفكرة أكتر فاهم قصدي.
Learner B1: عايزة تسألي الناس المسؤولة عن التدريب والناس اللي فعلا بيدربوا صح.
Learner B3: سبونس نفسهم حسألهم همين الموضوع ده بس إحنا بقى في الأسئلة دي ممكن نسأل يوزر إنت إيه مشكلتك إنه يكون في تو فيرجينس أو هل لو انت اللي اخترت فيريجن هل ده بالنسبة لك الموضوع؟ يبقى أحسن
Learner B3: يعني.
Learner B1: بس.
Learner B3: عشانكم.
Learner B7: من بالظبط.
Learner B3: يعني كل الجيوب واخدين أو يعني مثلا أنا كنت في الجروب التاني كانوا شغالين على بتنزل أو أنا ما كنتش عارفة أصلا. إن إنتو شغالين على ده يعني مكنتش عارفة إن في غروب تانية عشان أنا عملت، على فهو أصلا شغالة على تاس ثاني فهو
Learner B3: كان في حاجة كده فهمي قصدي.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: فاهمة قصدي بس مش عارفة ده إيه
Learner B7: سوري بجد أنا مش فاهمة علاقته بالموضوع يعني أنا فهمت قصدك بس أنا مش حاصلي.
Learner B3: أوكي.
Learner B7: قوي.
Learner B3: العلاقة إن هو في كان في ناس يعني كانت بتقول إن دي حاجة مضايقاها
Learner B3: يعني كان في حد كتب حاطط مش فاكرة كان كم حد قال أو فيدباك قد بس كان في حد قال إنه هو كل مختلف. وكان في ناس بتقول التاسيس إن كومبليت
Learner B3: فأنا شايفة إن إحنا نسألهم أكتر هو المدايقهم في ده
Learner B3: فنحن لما ندي سولوشن حتبقى مبنية على حاجات أصلا هم إتقالت يعني وكده نسألهم الأسئلة دي فاهمين بس.
Learner B1: هو هو الأسئلة دي مبنية من على كلامهم يعني أنا أنا بالأسئلة دي
Learner B1: من من خلال تفكيري تمام وبرضه لسه باقي الأسئلة نوضح كده بس الفكرة إيه هدف الفورم دي أو السربي دي إننا مثلا أعرف فلان الفلاني رأيه كده
Learner B1: أخش وأكلمه انتربيه واعرف رأيي أكتر.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: أيوة أيوة.
Learner B3: لأن فاهمة قصدك على حسب برضه إحنا ممكن نزود حاجات أكثر برضه اللي هو يعني مثلا لو
Learner B3: لو زي ما قلتلك حكيت لي اشتكوا فيها لو قلنا لو ده مثلا ده تبقى حاجة بالنسبة لك أحسن أو كده حسب.
Learner B1: عشان ما ننساش الكلام ده ممكن تكتبيه في الشاي دلوقتي يعني لو ملقيناش سؤال بيحكي عن كده ممكن اكتبي الجزء دلوقتي عشان ما تنتبهوش ولا عشان أنا ما أنسا
Learner B1: ونشوف بقى الأسئلة مافيش سؤال مثلا مافيش مشكلة.
Learner B3: خلاص أوكي.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B7: إحنا ممكن نعمل حاجة تحاكي الريتر ده؟ يعني هل هل كان في هل كان في عدد كبير جدا؟ مشارك في الرتور ده
Learner B7: كم حضرتوش بصراحة.
Learner B1: مش 99 اللي هم موجودين في.
Learner B7: أقل بكتير ولا.
Learner B3: بس أنا قد إيه أنا ممكن أبعت اللينك بتاع ال
Learner B3: الناس الي كتبوا حاجات ممكن تفتحها من ابعتها.
Learner B1: ما معي.
Learner B3: معك أصلا.
Learner B1: ثانية واحدة معايا.
Learner B3: بعتهالك أسهل طريقة.
Learner B1: ماشي ممكن.
Learner B3: جات.
Learner B1: الجيت.
Learner B1: ، قابلة انتو شايفنها.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: طب منكمل باقي الأسئلة.
Learner B3: خلاص كمل،
Learner B1: تمام الأول انتوا شايفين ده تمام ولا لأ احداثك بعد أو عايزين تغيروا حاجة يعني
Learner B1: ولا مش مقتنعين بيه.
Learner B5: أنا شايفه. إنه تمام.
Learner B7: حساء ريب من خبرتك قد
Learner B1: لا خبرتك قد أنا عايز أعرف هو هو فعلا خبرته قد ما أول ما دخل التدريب؟ دا أنا هدفي اعرف
Learner B1: إن هو كان طب.
Learner B7: كعضو مثلا.
Learner B1: لا
Learner B1: فاهم الدنيا من البداية يعني قبل ما يدفع قبل ما يدخل الإنترنت فاهم ان هو حيبقى في اي وهيبقى في مهندس أحمد منصور هدر تمام
Learner B1: تمام ولا ولا مش مهندس أحمد يوسف مثلا فاهم الدنيا ماشية ازاي ولا لأ ولا مثلا هو محتاج شوية عشان فاهم محتاج شوية وقت
Learner B1: عشان.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B1: هشيل. أنا مضايقني و وأنا لحد دلوقتي هو مش فاهم أصلا وشايف إن هو مستفاد حاجة.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة لو إنت تسأل بال بريسكتيف ده فممكن تخلي السؤال اللي هو هل فاهم مثلا نظام الإنترنشب قبل ما تدخل
Learner B3: عشان هو ممكن يبقى إحساسه عامة يعني فعلا زي ما هي بتقول اللي هو جنرال فممكن تتلخبط بإحساس الفيل نفسه.
Learner B1: يعني قصدك أول ما دخلت التدريب؟ هل.
Learner B3: زي مثلا نظام نفسها ماشي ازاي.
Learner B7: ممكن يديرو النسب للفحم يختاروا النسبة بتاعته منها.
Learner B1: لا، لا، هي.
Learner B3: هل كان عندك خلفية بنظام ال إنترنت قبل ما تدخل.
Learner B1: هو ده سؤال مباشر خليني اوكي اول ما دخلت.
Learner B7: كان.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: أنا مثلا حسب الملحوظ معنا في.
Learner B1: اليوم.
Learner B7: يعني أنا شايفة أكتر يعني منكتبش سؤال ينفع يجاوب أو لا أكتر ما هو ينفع نجاوب بإجابة.
Learner B1: فرانك.
Learner B3: تمام.
Learner B1: أنت فاهم نظام.
Learner B7: يعني أول ما دخلت كنت فاهم نظام التدريب
Learner B7: كنت فاهم لأ ما كنتش فاهم نص نص طب أنا ممكن أسأله كنت فاهم بنسبة قد إيه كأني بسأل هو ممكن يبان شبهه بس ما يخليني داخلة في الموضوع. أكتر إجاب سؤال ما ينفعش إجابته بآه، أو لأ.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة أنا حاسة بوينت دي حلوة قوي وحاسة كمان نحن ممكن تبقى حلوة لو حد حب يعمل الدنيا ممكن نقول أقل من 50 في المية أو أكتر من 50 في المية كده.
Learner B1: ما هو؟ فكرة أنا عرفت إن هو فاهم الدنيا بنسبة تمام أنا استفدت إيه
Learner B1: من هو كده الخمسين في المية دول استفادوا من قد
Learner B1: اللي نقصده ممكن يكون اللي نقصده إنه ممكن يكون تيم اللي كلمه عشان يشترك ما فهمهوش إن هو إيه
Learner B1: ما فاهمه كل حاجة قبل ما يخش يعني هو ودي بتعكس كده اللي هو احتجت شوية وقت عشان أفهم
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B7: على فكرة هو أنا لما جيت أدفع الفلوس. أنا دخلت على الموقع بتاعهم دفعت الفلوس وحد كلمني إن أنا أبعت ال
Learner B7: إننا.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: حجز وكدا بس يعني محدش أصلا وضح تفاصيل.
Learner B1: إن.
Learner B7: و.
Learner B1: تمشي بعدي خالص لذيذة.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: تمام دلوقتي إنت دلوقتي يعني لو حطينا نسبة 50 في المية 20 في المية النقطة دي حتفهمك ال
Learner B1: أتهمك. أنهي المشكلة كانت فين.
Learner B7: ممكن
Learner B7: ايوا انت شايف لأ.
Learner B1: مش مقتنعة مش شايف ولا.
Learner B7: على فكرة دي بالضبط شبه حتة التوقعات شوية هي ملامسة شوية توقعات
Learner B7: يعني هي ممكن تكون مش شبها بالظبط مش كان إجابتين واحدة بس هي يعني ملامسة شوية توقعات اللي أنا متوقعها وأنا داخل ما أنا مش فاهم قوي،
Learner B7: فأنا بنيت توقعات أكتر حسب ما دام مخلانيش ما خلانيش إن أنا أدخل وأستفسر بتفاصيل زيادة عن اللزوم.
Learner B7: لا، أنا كنت فاهم بنسبة كبيرة فده خلاني برضه توقعاتي يعني واقعية. أكتر
Learner B7: فهمني فده برضو بيلمس في التوقعات شوية وده اكيد حيفرق طبعا في الإجابة يعني حتفرق.
Learner B1: عارفة لو قال لي مثلا إيه لو قالي مثلا 20 في المية
Learner B1: طب أنا حعرف منين أنا 20 في المية دي هو فاهمها منين أو من.
Learner B7: إنت قصدك مش عايز لغة الأرقام يعني.
Learner B1: لغة الأرقام مش هتبين هو فاهم الدنيا من قبل ما يخشيب ولا من
Learner B1: يعني 20 في المية اللي هو فاهمهم دول فهمتهم. ايمتى فهمتهم مثلا بعد ما دخلت الإنتاج خالص وفهماك الدنيا.
Learner B7: ولا أنت كاتب السؤال أول ما دخلت.
Learner B1: ما هو ماشي؟ كنت فاهم النظام
Learner B1: أبليش أول ما أول لما خليها لما.
Learner B3: هل نحن مثلا تشرب.
Learner B1: ورقة.
Learner B3: كنت مثلا هل توضحلك التفاصيل؟ ولا هل دي ما امم.
Learner B1: هتبان قوي لما اشتركت لما اشتركت في التدريب.
Learner B3: طب مش دي البوينت أصلا. هو يبقى السؤال دايريكت.
Learner B1: معناها. حاولت أخرج دايريكت وخليته كدا هو.
Learner B7: هو المشكلة مش في وقت
Learner B7: هو المشكلة مش في وقت بعد التدريب. ولا وقت الاشتراك المشكلة في الجزء التاني من السؤال.
Learner B7: ما يبدأش بكلمة. هل.
Learner B1: ماهوش بادئ بال.
Learner B7: يعني كنت فاهم نظام التدريب هي دي كإنها. هل كنت فاهم بس بلغة أهمية يعني اجابة برضه ولاء.
Learner B1: لا مش عايز لا أنا أنت كنت فاهم فاهم الدنيا احتجت شوية احتجت شوية دلوقتي لحد دلوقتي في حاجة مش واضحة.
Learner B7: تمام كويس طب خلاص كدا اشتركت بقى عشان تبقى عارف ممكن يكون قصده دخلت ده لما خدت تذكر
Learner B7: ففعلا زي ما انت عدلتها في الأول مثلا.
Learner B1: خلينا برضه إيه يعني لعل يدخل معنا.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B1: إمم
Learner B7: الحمد لله.
Learner B1: أول حاجة عملتها مع السلامة.
Learner B7: بدرت تشتغل.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B1: مباشرة. قريت التعليمات أكتر شو اسمه؟ تمام؟
Learner B1: سألت الإيغ سألت المندوب. سألت حضرتك ما.
Learner B7: في ناس كتير تخاف ترد لو سألت الإيه رغم ان كلنا سألنا الإيه مثلا إيه تفضلي.
Learner B1: منا عامل لدي تحت.
Learner B3: طب إنت ليه مساحة إنت مساحة
Learner B1: أنا نصحت عشان كده أخبرها من هنا اتفرجت على فيديو أو يعني شلت اللي هو ثانية وحدة
Learner B1: بحث على جوجل على بعض. وعملت بحث.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B7: فيديو.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة كده لأن أنا ممكن في ناس مثلا فرجت على فيديوس بس أو.
Learner B1: لا يعتبر بحث كمثر.
Learner B7: لأ ممكن عاملة سيرش وفي ناس عملت بحث زي ياسر ياسر ياسر دخل فيديو اليوتيوب ازاي بنعمل ده.
Learner B3: وفي.
Learner B7: في.
Learner B3: بحس بس وما فيديوهات.
Learner B1: يعني.
Learner B7: الورود الأحمر بالنسبة لي الصراحة ممكن ابقى خلاص.
Learner B1: دي إي. آي أم.
Learner B7: الإي آي ده اللي هو إي آي بتاعنا ولا إي آي اللي هو مثلا.
Learner B1: هو معلش المتور يعتبر إيه المتور الموجود اللي هو المهندس أحمد منصور ولا ولا مينتر المقصود.
Learner B7: ايوا عمر مين اذا مش سورة هي المنتر.
Learner B5: المفروض. انهم سي آي.
Learner B1: سؤال بس عشان إيه اللي هو مش مهندس أحمد منصور ولا مش مهندس أحمد أحمد يوسف.
Learner B7: نعم، مش مكتوب سارة.
Learner B5: فوز هو مكتوب. أدمن
Learner B5: المنتر لا مش مكتوب أحمد مرزوق.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B7: ممكن. سألت حد سألت في استفسرت عن الجد أو سألت اللي بعتلك الطاستك أو ممكن نسأل مثلا
Learner B7: سألت إي آي تول.
Learner B5: أيوه.
Learner B1: والله بايخة كده.
Learner B3: ولا الإي آي يعني وكذا.
Learner B1: لا اللي فهمو إن المنتشر ده اللي هو مش مهندس محمد يوسف بس مهندس مردوء.
Learner B7: لأ دول مش منطرت خالص باغين دول مينتورز.
Learner B5: هو مش المفروض يبقى أحمد منصور علشان هو اللي بيكلمنا على طول هو وصرف.
Learner B7: لا سارة مكتوب جنبها إحنا ممكن يا جماعة نسهلها على نفسنا قوي ممكن نقول هل استخدمت
Learner B5: موضوع.
Learner B7: ولا ولا سألت حد من التيم في البرنت أو أي حاجة يعني وعايزة حساسة أبسط منقوم.
Learner B1: بصي حد من ال تيم دا يعني حد من الجيم اللي معانا يعني اللي هو زيك زينب و ندى وجاسر دول حد من التين. تمام المنتور
Learner B1: مقصود بيها لأنا فاهمه اللي هو باش مهندس أحمد يوسف اللي بيحضروا معنا محمد يوسف.
Learner B7: ماشي.
Learner B1: تمام إي آي تمام ده اللي أنا فهمه اللي هو إيه.
Learner B7: في آي تول ولا قصدك سارة.
Learner B1: ثورة تمام.
Learner B7: لا محدش هيفهمها نياها سارة خالص.
Learner B1: بالضبط أنا هدفي.
Learner B7: آي طولي طول.
Learner B3: الأولى.
Learner B1: ماشي سألت دلوقتي عايز أعرفه عايز أعرف هو. استخدم سآل ثورة ولا.
Learner B7: وأكيد حتى لو صار سارة أكيد سارة ما ردتش.
Learner B1: عايز أعرف هو عمل
Learner B3: بس ليه بس هي ما بترد عادي.
Learner B1: أه أهو بتاع تذكرة.
Learner B7: شو رد تفاصيل.
Learner B3: أم أوكي.
Learner B5: ممكن نخليها إيه آي أدمن.
Learner B7: جمال جدا. عايزة أقول بجد ممكن يكون فعلا ناس كتير مش عارفة لسه ان هم.
Learner B5: حتى.
Learner B7: حد بعتلي الفورم لو حد بعتلي الفورم دي قبل ما أنتو تقولولي أنا ما كنتش عارفة إنت قصدك على مين
Learner B7: شو يعني.
Learner B3: أوقاتل هيومن بيدخل.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: احنا ممكن نسميهم بوجه عام كده ما نقولش حاجة.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B3: اتنين ممكن تتفاهم فعلا كده أو ممكن تتفاهم.
Learner B1: أيوة.
Learner B3: الخميس.
Learner B1: أم إسمه أحمد منصور أم
Learner B1: للناس خبرة برضو مفروض نحترمهم يا جماعة.
Learner B7: قدام.
Learner B7: فبراير 3 تيام.
Learner B1: لا خمستشر سنة أو 10 سنين.
Learner B7: مايكل نو هيومن على فكرة.
Learner B7: أنكن وهيومن.
Learner B1: مش.
Learner B7: أكيد يوم يعني.
Learner B1: ماشي يختار 3 بس صح ولا أكتر.
Learner B7: سؤال هل هم يعني مثلا هل هم موجودين في لكل لكل التراكتس اللي موجودة ولا لينا إحنا بس.
Learner B1: كل لما فتحت.
Learner B7: هل حابة أعرف المعلومات؟ دي.
Learner B1: لو فرحت الجنرال لو في كل هتلاقيهم هم اللي بيكتبوا هم اللي بيرد.
Learner B7: أيوة يبقى هم.
Learner B1: أقنعتك.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B1: كل إيه بقى خليه يختار تلاتة بس ولا أكتر.
Learner B5: اليوم 4.
Learner B7: تونس زهرة المنتج طب ثانية وايه فرق بين المتر وال واحمد منصور وسارة.
Learner B1: المنتور البصر.
Learner B1: قشطة لنا فهم بودرة.
Learner B7: هو ما فيش حد منهم اصلا بيرد علينا في ال فلاشات أصلا.
Learner B1: مين اللي دخل معك على مين اللي دخل عمل فيدك اسمنت.
Learner B7: أيوه.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: أيوا بس ده إنت بتقول أول ما بدأت تشتغل على أول ما خدت ال تاسست.
Learner B7: ما دخلوش معانا في البداية دخلوا معانا بيبقى في الآخر.
Learner B1: هو في الميلاني.
Learner B7: أيوة مش في أول حاجة.
Learner B1: هو أول حاجة مش مهندس مثلا مين أحمد منصور دخل معنا في وقال لنا
Learner B1: إيه الكتب اللي بتحبوها إيه الكتب اللي قرأتوها والتذكرة عبارة عن والترينت ماشية ازاي ده في أول يوم.
Learner B7: أنا فاكرة بصراحة، كنت فاكر أكتر مني بس أنا فاكر كنا منكلمه أصلا كان بياخد مننا كان فيدباك كده أو كم حاجة أصلا يحسنها؟ فالتدريب أنا فاكرة ده
Learner B7: و وسألنا عن كل 1 فينا شاف مشاكل بتاعت التشارن ريد ديات كل 1 كان شايفها ازاي،
Learner B7: فأنا فاكرة إحنا ألريدي اشتغلنا
Learner B7: بس أنا كنت فاكر أكتر مني.
Learner B1: حد معانا حد شارك معانا يا جماعة، أرجوك.
Learner B7: أنا فاكرة إن كان في كده حاجة يبقى هو نوتس كده كل 1 فينا أقل حاجة كان يفضل إن أنا أكون موجودة في في الإنترنت كاول تاسك خالص
Learner B7: كل 1 فينا قال حاجة وبعد كده كل 1 فينا شارك الحاجات اللي هو فكر فيها. كمشاكل حصلت لما كان صار على.
Learner B1: مش بكلمك عن.
Learner B7: خلاص أنا مش فاكرة خلاص خلاص.
Learner B1: إيه طب حد يعني حد فاكر تاني أو حد حيجي على حاجة تاني.
Learner B3: أنا بس أحس إن إحنا ممكن عادي ونقول سألت آي تول. وسألت سبينس مثلا تين أو سبينس
Learner B3: اي ايمنتس حاسة يعني الموضوع بسيط.
Learner B1: عائلتي إيمانيش.
Learner B3: مثلا تيم.
Learner B1: عندي يهان على البصر.
Learner B3: طيب أنا بس مشكلتي في كلمة اللي بيدخلوا يدونا فيدباك الحقيقيين.
Learner B1: ا بالضبط.
Learner B7: هون
Learner B7: بما أنهم 2 بس كان عادي نكتب أسمائهم مثلا يعني بما أنهم مش أكثر من 2 فا حاسه عادي لو كتبنا أسمائهم.
Learner B3: طيب خلاص ماشي.
Learner B7: لا أنا مش متأكدة من إجابتي. أنا مش هيك بس.
Learner B3: مش عارفة غرفتها يعني.
Learner B5: ممكن نكتبهم أدمن بما إنه هو مكتوب قدامهم. أدمن هولي.
Learner B3: ممكن صح.
Learner B7: ممكن نخليها هيومن مينور واي منتور وبس ولا نسميهم.
Learner B1: برضه أنا مش عايز ألعب في ناس فاكراهم بشر يفتكروهم.
Learner B7: خلاص يبقى نكتب اساميهم
Learner B7: في حد سارة في حد أحمد أحمد منصور خلاص سألت سارة ولا أحمد منصور وحاجات تانية. سألترز الموجودين معنا بيدخلوا معانا
Learner B7: الريتروميتينغز وال والحاجات دي ولا إمرأة الناس اللي هم موجودين نفسهم.
Learner B5: ممكن. تبقى سألت سبرينت أدمن.
Learner B1: أنا ممكن مش موافق على بس يا رب.
Learner B5: ممكن بس يعني ممكن هم أشخاص غير أشخاص فيعني هيقدروا يفرقوا بين الاتنين خصوصا إن أحمد منصور وسارة نادر هم اللي معانا على طول هم اللي بيردوا على كل
Learner B5: لكن الباقي بيدخله الرتر بس.
Learner B1: أم يخلوها اي اختار.
Learner B7: على فكرة يعني على فكرة إنت لو كتبت مثلا أد من أو كذا هم هم بيقروا الإسم اللي تحته
Learner B7: فأنا بعرف مين مينتول عرفت عشان مكتوب تحتها ما عرفتش عرفت أحمد منصور كانش مكتوب تحته قدو
Learner B7: هو كده فلما إنت تقولي سألت القد مين حبقى عارفة إن هو ده سألت المتر عارفة إن هو ده
Learner B7: فهو مش واخد بالو دا بني آدم ولا لأ هو عارف ده اسمه وده اسمه
Learner B1: تمام، وأنا سألت إي أدمن.
Learner B7: سأتأكد منه طيب ممكن نكتب سارة وأحمد من عنصر وخلاص
Learner B7: أنا حاسة إن إحنا سايبين أهم حاجة في الحياة لسا قديمة.
Learner B3: مع الصفر راكدين بتفصيلة أوي.
Learner B1: استغرقت قد عشان تنفذ لا ضمائر.
Learner B7: أنا كنت مخزر إنت بجد سايبها بالدقايق.
Learner B1: و.
Learner B5: الأرقام بحقيقة.
Learner B1: ده عظمة أوي ناسية مبارح كان بيحاسبنا بإيه بساعات في الدقايق.
Learner B7: بيقول لنا لا كان بيقولنا أكتر.
Learner B5: على.
Learner B7: ساعة إنت كاتب تلاتين دقيقة. هو كان بيسألك تلاتين ساعة.
Learner B1: بالضبط عشان نجلد الناس.
Learner B5: لا.
Learner B7: ده سؤال يعني بصراحة ممكن حد أصلا يعملك.
Learner B3: فأكيد أقل من 30 دقيقة يعني.
Learner B7: هو إلى.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B5: خليها.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B5: كم ساعة و40 ساعة. زي ما هو كان مبارح. كنت.
Learner B7: لا بلاش بلاش بجد يا جماعة بلاش تلاتين ساعة وكده ممكن نقوله في اليوم خدت قد حساها أنا تلاتين ساعة ما كنت برا فحسبها أنا كنت.
Learner B1: الساعتين.
Learner B7: شوية.
Learner B1: أكثر من ساعتين.
Learner B1: خليها مثلا؟ هيه، هيا، اسمعوا معايا قولوا هيا.
Learner B3: رائب اليوم فعلا منطقية أكثر يعني.
Learner B5: أيوا.
Learner B7: باليوم فعلا التذكر بياخد اسبوع فلأ يعني ساعات قليلة أوي يمكن بسبب الأيام.
Learner B3: ممكن أقل من يوم مثلا.
Learner B1: هم كانوا عاملين تخلي التذكرة 4 ساعات في اليوم.
Learner B7: أنا أتوقع ده للتذكرة شوية بس بصراحة أول أسبوع ما كنتش متخيل أول أسبوع كان يدوب بتفكر في حل بس.
Learner B1: هم كانوا عاملين 4 ساعات في اليوم لا حتى لما قلناله تمانيه
Learner B1: معقول علشان احنا كان في توس برينت.
Learner B7: مش عارفة بس كنت حساسة أو شعباني.
Learner B1: مش مهم معك
Learner B7: شو لغات.
Learner B1: يا ولدي سعيد.
Learner B7: قررت وقت قد قبل ما عشان تبدأ
Learner B7: أيوا ثانية إنت سؤالك مختلف أصلا.
Learner B1: عشان تفهم التذكرة.
Learner B7: أيوة إحنا بنجاوبك على ان احنا خلصنا شو يا عيدك بس.
Learner B3: أنا فهمتها كده برضه.
Learner B1: لذيذة دي حتبين هو إصراحة قد إيه بتتغير صح؟
Learner B7: أن.
Learner B3: يعني هذا السؤال نفسه ممكن يتفهم فعلا كده لو اخدت وقت قد عشان تخلص أنا نفسي فهمت.
Learner B7: التنفيذ أو القصد.
Learner B3: ما ممكن يفهموا تأخذ وقت في تنفيذ
Learner B3: مش عارف حسن، كيف فهم غلط.
Learner B1: أعمل إيه.
Learner B7: تقدر تشتغل تشتغل يا تشتغل تنفيذ ممكن تقولي إنت نفذت التوست خلاص كنت تبدأ تشتغل.
Learner B3: ممكن أزود بس وقت قد عشان تفهم التاسكو وتبدأ شغل.
Learner B7: ممكن برضه.
Learner B1: عشان تفهم الباص.
Learner B7: وإحنا سألنا سؤال عن الفهم قبل ده تقريبا برضه ولا
Learner B1: ده عملت إيه لما استلمت
Learner B1: نخليه سؤال العين كدا في الآخر عشان الحتة بتاعت الأدمن تمام تمام أكتر حاجة حضرتك قبل ما نبدأ.
Learner B7: يكتب جميع ما سبق الله يخليك.
Learner B1: كل الناس سنختارها من غير ما.
Learner B7: أنا أدخل أكثرها مخصوص كم المطلوب تسليمه هما 5 بس ولا طب.
Learner B5: كريم.
Learner B5: دي.
Learner B7: تفضل.
Learner B5: معاي.
Learner B1: لا حضرتك قبل ما تبدأ هو لسه ما بدأش هو لسه كدا من برا كدا بيقرأ التزق
Learner B1: لسه.
Learner B7: أنا مصدومة.
Learner B5: اكتب والمزوبف. لو سمحت.
Learner B1: إن كل الناس هنختارهم لا كلنا ما فيش.
Learner B3: بس هو في أوبشن إنك تختار كذا حاجة صح؟
Learner B7: وإن ساعة فلوس على كل.
Learner B1: تلاهي أخرك 3 ثانية واحدة. تفضلي.
Learner B3: ده لا في ناس فعلا ممكن يبقى أكثر من 3 يعني.
Learner B1: يختار.
Learner B5: ما.
Learner B7: الأولويات أولويات.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B3: إيه.
Learner B7: أكيد تكون كفاية.
Learner B1: هو أنا عايز أضيف حاجة بس مش
Learner B1: مش عارف أضيف إيه عايز أضيف اللي هو لو كان إيه لا.
Learner B7: كم متاح لأديتك وانت تعمل
Learner B1: لأ لأ مش أكثر حاجة أخرى. قبل ما نبدأ بالتوست أنا مثلا أكتر حاجة
Learner B1: خارتني قبل ما أبدأ بالتسك إن كان
Learner B1: توسك من الإي آي أول حاجة كانت مختلفة عن الدرايم ارتيبول
Learner B1: حد يعرف يصيغ إجابة توصف الكلام اللي أنا قلته ده والله أصلي.
Learner B7: فهمي المطلوب على.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B7: تقريبا كانت عندك إنت بس أنا أنا بصراحة، كنت شايفة إن البير دي كان بيوصف المشكلة من جوا إنما التاسك بيعرفك تسلمها ازاي بس يعني أنا عايز أول ما أبص على فايل ألاقي في كذا وكذا وكذا
Learner B7: فخلاص ردا يقرأوه زي زي كده هما عايزين شكل التاس كده لكن محتواه بقى ده بيتكتب في بي ار دي فأنا كنت فهمت ده.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B3: بس أنا فاهمة نظرك بس أنا حاسة فعلا هي دي كانت سبب يعني تفتت ناس كتير فإحنا، فعلا ممكن نحطها هي مش كل الناس فهمت كده زيك فاهمة.
Learner B7: ممكن.
Learner B1: أحطها إزاي بقى أوصفها ازاي يعني دلوقتي.
Learner B7: كمان مطلوب
Learner B3: مثلا.
Learner B1: في
Learner B1: ممكن المطلوب ده يعني إيه يعني أنا فعلا قريت يعني قريت هش هش هش هش.
Learner B7: وإحنا ممكن مثلا نخليها سؤال تاني نقول له في التاسك ولا المسج بتاعك.
Learner B1: كل الناس قال مش مش كل الناس قالها بي أر دي
Learner B1: تمام إحنا مش مش إحنا مش نركب برودكت بس من من.
Learner B7: أيوة صح صح.
Learner B1: دلوقتي مثلا زي البير دي الوقت فاهم المطلوب أنا أريد ده كله تمام.
Learner B1: وما تمام بس مش ده اللي أنا عملته أو ده اللي أنا أقصده. لا اللي أقصده إن أنا قريته
Learner B1: عريض بتاع ممكن تعدد المصادر بس لا يفهموها.
Learner B7: بس أنا طالما طالما إنت لسه قايل إن مفيش غير نحنا بس تيمين برودكت اللي خد بي آر دي فإذن السؤال ده هيبقى بتاعنا إحنا بس.
Learner B3: متأكد بس ما فيش حد غيرنا خده.
Learner B1: يعني.
Learner B7: يعني لو.
Learner B1: يا جماعة لو نقصده إن فين فين
Learner B1: مثلا ده اللي ياخد بيه أل دي
Learner B1: البوليستيك لي ياخد بي أر دي
Learner B3: من عندك يعني.
Learner B1: أكيد حياخذوا طسك مختلفة إذا كان إنت بتقولي إنك كنت معانا في البرودكت في برودكت. وكان في اختلاف ما بين التزكات.
Learner B7: في فرق بين اختلاف التذكرات، وإن هي ما كانتش في أرضي أصلا.
Learner B1: ما أعرفش لأ ما مش كل مش كل دول ما أعتقدش ما أقدرش أجمع.
Learner B3: طب إحنا ممكن نخليه طب في سؤال لوحده مثلا ممكن تقول هل مثلا تعدد المصادر سبب لك مثلا مشكلة.
Learner B1: دايريكت.
Learner B3: المشكلة. في دايريكت معي. حسن، دي الفكرة.
Learner B7: سؤال لو لو إجابته ترد مش حتأزيني يعني عادي لو سألته.
Learner B3: أنا لازم أفهم أصل دايريكت عشان أعرف فعلا متأكدة.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: أيواه يا فندم حتى مش محتاجة في السؤال ده.
Learner B3: بالظبط المفتوح بيتفاهم ب 1,000,000 طريقة.
Learner B1: تعدد المصادر أوفرت.
Learner B7: ممكن نقولهم هل كان في كذا مصدر للتسك؟ أنا.
Learner B3: نعم.
Learner B7: الحراك في
Learner B3: إحنا ممكن نقول مثلا في الاختيارات يعني إن هو بالنسبة لي كان أحسن لأن هو فهمني بكذا طريقة أو بالنسبة لي كان بلخبط أو كده يعني.
Learner B7: أيوة مثلا ممكن ناخذ الأول ده حتة كمان يعني مثلا إيه هل ده فاهمك أكتر هل ده كذا ولا أصلا مصدر 1 يعني نخلي السؤال ده عبارة عن اختيار في الآخر أصلا ما نعملهوش منفصل
Learner B7: فهمتوني ولا
Learner B3: هلأ أنا حاسة بطل أحسن لإنه دي كانت مشكلة كبيرة عندهم فحسى أكون دايما.
Learner B7: خلاص بقول كده بالزبط ما هو دايريكت بس في الفكرة أنا ما عملوش سؤال لوحده يعني اعملوا لهيئة اختيارات.
Learner B7: هي.
Learner B3: الأولى.
Learner B7: قولي طيب.
Learner B3: الله. لا قولي قولي سامعاكي.
Learner B7: خلاص ماشي يعني هل أنا ممكن أقول هل إن وصلتلك من كذا مصدر ده لغبطك أكتر؟ ولا قدرت توازي ما بينهم. ولا أنت أصلا ما وصلكش ولا اعتمدت على مصدر ولا أصلا وصلك منظر 1
Learner B7: يعني مولوش وصلك ولا لأ
Learner B7: وناخد من المعلومة بس المعلومة موجودة في اختيار ألريدي يعني.
Learner B3: ده كان قصدي فذكرت إن إنت عايز تحطيه مع السؤال اللي قبليت كدا.
Learner B7: إمم
Learner B7: وعندي كريم. أنا مش عايز يسوق.
Learner B3: لا لا إحنا ساكتين.
Learner B7: سوري.
Learner B7: هاف إي.
Learner B1: تعدد المصادر.
Learner B3: يعني في لخبطة ممكن ما وصلنيش أصلا زي ما هي قالت.
Learner B7: التذكر كان من مصدر 1 اصلا بس.
Learner B1: لو لسه لسه الواحد لغاية دلوقتي فاهم الواحد ربنا يهينه.
Learner B7: ممكن يجوا في الآخر فعلا هم مصدر 1.
Learner B1: مصدر 1. 2.
Learner B5: هي دي مش مفهومة.
Learner B7: إنت أصلا لسه قايل بلسانك إن مش كل 1 واصله بأرض دي إنت ليه كلامك متناقض.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B7: مش كله واصله بي آر دي الوقت ليه بتقوله هو يكون مصدر 1.
Learner B1: التوسك من منبر 1 لو حد اختار الإجابة دي
Learner B1: هو اتصل بيه تبعت لنا من مصدرين تمام
Learner B1: 1 لإيه اللي هو أستاذ أحمد منصور
Learner B1: و1 تاني اللي هو ارتي بولي تمام
Learner B1: لو حد لسا لو حد اختار دي فهو لغاية، اللحظة دي مش موقع حاجة بينهم
Learner B1: يا موقع الإي آي موقع اللي هو إيه ارتيبو.
Learner B7: إذن ده بيثبت إن إن كل 1 مبعوت له باردي وتزكي من ال إي آي
Learner B7: إذا الموضوع ده مش عندنا إحنا بس برودكت مانجرست.
Learner B1: أنا دي المعلومة دي مش عايز أكتب.
Learner B3: أنا مثلا عندي سؤال عندي أنا حاسة إن إنت ممكن كان في لخبطة تغيرها حسيت بلغبطة لأن كان في لخبطة ممكن تتفهم إن التاسسك نفسه كان ملخبط.
Learner B1: التذكرة ملغمطة على فكرة.
Learner B3: ما ممكن يعني نحطها بقى في حاجتين بس إحنا قوي عشان نفهم بالظبط وشرحت التاسك بشكل أوضح ممكن برضه تغيرها لفهمت التاسك بشكل أوضح لأني شرحت ممكن ده يفهمها إن أنا يعني عملت التاسك بشكل أوضح.
Learner B1: عندك.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B1: الأول هنا اللغة أثرت يعني هل ده سبب.
Learner B7: اللغة المكي أكيد لو في حاجة
Learner B7: كان كان مش مش إنغلس كده تفهمه بنفسك بنسبة مية في المية عادي كان ممكن تزرج كم حاجة منهم عادي.
Learner B1: غرضي أسيب أسيب الاختيار ده ولا.
Learner B3: أنا حاسس.
Learner B1: في في إجماع في إجماع ما حدش على غلط اختلاف التعليمات دي أعترضها لأ.
Learner B7: لا بصيغيب التعليمات دي ممكن مش عارفة ممكن تكون اختلاف الصياغة.
Learner B7: أصلك انت خليت ان هنا في شرق وهنا في الغرب.
Learner B1: إمم باختلاف ال.
Learner B7: صياغة التوستك بس ده كله طبعا بفرض إن كل الناس عندها تاسك من ال طبعا.
Learner B1: أم تمام
Learner B7: فهل أصلا نسأل قبل ما نحط السؤال.
Learner B1: ولا مش مهندس أحمد حيشوفو بقى يشوف.
Learner B7: مين أحسن؟ ماشي.
Learner B1: أحمد.
Learner B3: على من سيسموا
Learner B3: أنا أصلا. شايفة إن عندك حق يعني حاسة إن في حاجات إحنا محتاجين نفهمها من التين تين بيعملوها كده قبل ما أصلا ما نسأل يوزرز.
Learner B7: ممكن نشوف الفلول ممكن نشوف الفلول اللي بعتت.
Learner B1: أكيد.
Learner B7: إزاي.
Learner B1: هي انبعتت يا جماعة انبعتت حد بعثها.
Learner B7: أيوه بعدها بعتها لندى كان في ساعة. اللي أنا طلبت فيه أيوة هو ده.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B7: هو ده اللي تحت اللي هو مكتوب حيكون لا من قبل.
Learner B1: ممكن أحيانا باهي.
Learner B7: أيوة هو ده.
Learner B1: ذيغما طيب ولا في إيه.
Learner B7: نقدرو.
Learner B1: لا حول ولا قوة إلا بالله لا إله إلا الله.
Learner B7: في.
Learner B1: إلى العكس كده ده
Learner B1: طب يا جماعة لو حد قرايب أخته ممكن يشرحلي.
Learner B7: روب صراحة.
Learner B1: كان.
Learner B5: أو.
Learner B7: أدور على الحتة بتاعت بقى.
Learner B1: تربط تربط التو تربط.
Learner B1: إذا ما فيش سيرش يا أستاذ يا أستاذ يا أستاذ.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B5: لا مش على سيرش.
Learner B7: في صرت تغنن.
Learner B1: يا بختك لو شايفاه، بجد ربنا يا بختك.
Learner B5: بريندي.
Learner B1: أختك لو شايفاه يا أختك لو شايفاه؟ أم طيب
Learner B1: لو بتعلمنا مش شايف انت ممكن توصفيني فين طيب خلينا نقرأ وحدة وحدة عشان كده قالولك ابعتليها
Learner B7: هامبوردينغ. هنا.
Learner B1: أيوه عند.
Learner B7: استسمنت برضه عادة تيكنيكال هومبوردينغ.
Learner B1: إيه اللي بيحصل واسعة وسع انت صورتك. انت مين ما نعرفوش.
Learner B7: محمد سرور دوست وورك سونت.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: شباك.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B7: ميش هيومان اكسبرس ثري هيومان اكس.
Learner B1: لا فقدان الشام.
Learner B7: ما إيه ما يحصلوش عليه.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: يعني ما يعتروش عليه دي.
Learner B1: أنا إيه.
Learner B7: بتاعة اليمن إكسبير.
Learner B1: إلكريم ده ما عرفش فاهم صح الغلط بس معنى كده إن المترو مش لازم يحضر فيه هيومن
Learner B1: ممكن يكون مدخلش يا سبحان الله.
Learner B7: يعني الحتة بتاعت الكوردونيتر والبي ام ويكلي فيدباك
Learner B7: يعني الكوردنيتور ده اللي هو
Learner B1: منظم.
Learner B7: أيوا دول مين.
Learner B1: ندين صح نديم.
Learner B7: البي ام دا مش أصدهم البي ام تيم صح؟ كان يعني.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B7: تمام يعني كنت بشوف لو احنا كدا بس نبعت فيدباك اصلا في الآخر ولا لأ.
Learner B1: لأ المفروض بيهم اللي جوا الشركة تمام.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: تمام وال بي إم هو حيبقى مسؤول يعني اعتقد
Learner B7: قلت ليه كده بينا توسك فروميشن ديتيلز. أهو.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: ميش.
Learner B1: مين ده.
Learner B7: ممكن تشوف نيوتس الصغيره دي.
Learner B1: فين.
Learner B7: لي.
Learner B1: يمين ولا تمانة.
Learner B7: طبعا وين فرقي لأ الشمال يحيى والتيم شبي إيكول أو فنتورنز
Learner B7: يعني يعني التاسكات لازم يكون وحدة عند كل انتيرن.
Learner B1: ممكن أعرف إنت بتعرفي فين هنا.
Learner B7: في نوت صغيرة كده لونها بيبي بلو تحت.
Learner B1: يحيى بكون إيكول عادة؟ هل أنت باهي.
Learner B7: فيرينتس أوف إيتش توت يعني
Learner B1: يعني اللي أنا فهمه أن إمم
Learner B1: إيه إن عدد التذاكرات اللي بتكون موجودة لازم بتساوي عدد
Learner B1: يعني مثلا لو 99 1 بيتضربوا 99. اتبعدت تقريبا هو كان في مشكلة.
Learner B7: لا أقصد لأ ممكن يكونوا شبه بعض
Learner B7: مش عارف حتى مش عارفة ممكن نستفيد منها ولا لا المعلومة دي.
Learner B1: أوف مغلوب لو في ديفنت إمم
Learner B1: يبقى مثلا أنا ودي مش من حقنا يكون عندنا فهماني.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: ما عرفش أيوة.
Learner B3: دي كانت مثلا أنا مثلا دي من الحاجات دي كانت موجودة في البلانينغ فلي بقى مثلا ممكن يوزرز ما عجبهمش حاجة زي كده هل مثلا مش عاجبهم عشان هم بس ما كانوش عارفين
Learner B3: ولا يعني أنا عايزة أعرف إيه اللي كدا إمم.
Learner B7: ممكن افتكر قصدك إن كل تيم
Learner B7: في نفس التراك ليه حاجة مختلفة.
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B7: ممكن مثلا عشان خاطر ممكن يحسوا
Learner B7: إن في ناس تانية واخدة حاجة مناسبة لمستوى تاني حتفيدهم أكتر ولا بدائي فممكن ما تدينيش حاجة تفيدني أكتر؟ لأن أنا لسه مبتدأ
Learner B7: فلو دي دايقته ممكن تكون فيها رغم انها في الاخر ممكن تكون ما تضايقش برضو.
Learner B3: أنا فاهمة بس أنا حاسة مثلا الموضوع ده كان بجد ممكن يتحلل لو كان الموضوع كتير من الأول اللي هو مثلا لو كان في حاجة بتوضح بتاعت الرود ماك يعني بتقول إن كل تين بياخد مختلف مكنش حد يعترض أوي يعني.
Learner B7: أنا مش حاسة إنها مشكلة بس لما أنا سمعتها دلوقتي حاسة ممكن أبقى عندي فضول واعرف انهم عندهم
Learner B3: هقولك حاجة بصراحة من بتاعتي أنا لما يعني عملت حاجة مختلفة بتاعكو أنا بصراحة كنت مبسوطة أكتر يعني أنا مبسوطة أكتر وأنا شغالة على
Learner B3: فأنا حاسة من حقي يوزر إن هو يختار بالذات لو جديد في المجال، فهو لو اختار حاجة أقربله، فممكن يحب المجال. أكثر. لو اختار حاجة صعبة أو مش مناسبة ممكن يكره المجال كله
Learner B3: فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: فاهمة قصدك قصدك إن تزكرة تيم بتاعنا أقرب للحاجة اللي إنت حاباها أكتر من التذكرة اللي خدتيها في تيم التاني
Learner B7: الأصدقاء.
Learner B3: حلوين بس أنا أنا بصراحة مبسوطة في تيست دي أكتر وأنا بالصدفة أصلا ما كنتش عارفة مختلفة يعني أنا كنت.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: أول مرة نكون دنيا مفتوح لنا شوية ولينا أكسس على حاجة.
Learner B1: كل الحاجات التانية.
Learner B7: كنا لا بجد كنا بنعطي الجامد.
Learner B1: هي بس يعني الطاس يمكن بس يعني كلام المهندس محمد امبارح قايل إن غلط أصلا.
Learner B7: أصل.
Learner B1: التذك كان تقصد لمريم عملت اللي هو دوروا عن المشكلة
Learner B1: ويقولولنا إيه هي المشكلة ويقولوا لنا الحل تمام.
Learner B3: صح؟ سؤالك.
Learner B7: سلام عليك مبارح.
Learner B3: أنا طب اتوقع.
Learner B7: طيب إنت ليه داخلة معانا الميكينغ مين قالك عليه.
Learner B3: هو أنا أصلا. هو أنا التاسكت بتاعتنا إن إحنا شغالين على شغالين على
Learner B3: أنا كان عندي مشكلة إن أنا عايزة ريل ديتا قوي فأنا استغليت بصراحة وأخدت داتا بتاعته واشتغلت عليها. فهو قال إن أنا عملت على وده تاسك جروب تاني أنا مش عارفة معاه فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: أيوة تمام.
Learner B1: إنت بقى يعني لما جيتي تدوري على المشكلة
Learner B1: كان في سكوب للمشكلة ولا كنتي بدوري براحتك.
Learner B3: لأ كان في سكوب عملت على الفيد باك عشان كده أنا بحاول يعني مهتمة قوي إن أنا أقدر.
Learner B1: للأسف أنا فيدباك بقى كان عندي فيه مشكلة يعني.
Learner B3: لي.
Learner B1: لو فيدباك فيدباك بعد إيمتى ولا كالفييد باك عموما.
Learner B3: لا رفيقك.
Learner B7: ما كنت ناقش.
Learner B3: اللي اتكتب وعملت عليه بروجكت كله التاسك قصدي كلو يعني.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B3: ما الفكرة هو دائما الكوماند بتاعهم إن إحنا نشتغل على فأنا بصراحة استغليتها قلت يعني بس.
Learner B1: ما.
Learner B3: يعني كان فيدباك.
Learner B1: في كل لغاية لما فقدت الشغب فقدت اديتها ومش عارف.
Learner B3: ابدا.
Learner B7: بتاعكو كان شغال على إيه أولتي.
Learner B3: هو شغال على وبصراحة أنا حاسة أنا حاسة كل حاجة ليها ميزة وعيب يعني حاسة ده حلو لأن هم في يعني سهل إن هم يدوروا أونلاين يسألوا ناس عامة فاهمة
Learner B3: لأن في كورسات في كل حتة يعني
Learner B3: بس ده يعني نسأل ناس في الانترجيت.
Learner B1: طيب اختلاف الصياغة دي متفقين عليها ولا لأ.
Learner B7: أمس.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: أصلا بالنسبة للي إنت قلتيه إحنا أول مرة نشتغل على حاجة ليها علاقة بأن إحنا نسأل ناس وكده قبل كده دائما كانت التذكرة بتبقى محدودة لمشكلة معينة.
Learner B3: أنا بعد ما سألتش حد.
Learner B7: يعني مثلا أول أول أسبوع لينا كان على بتاع الناس بتاخد كورسات فهمني امتنئ أسبوع.
Learner B1: شغل ومشي.
Learner B7: تاني أسبوع كان على إن ضغط ال التوست بيعمل
Learner B7: الضغط عند المتر فيخلي إن هو يتأخر. في إنه يدي يفيد باك فبالتالي إحنا كمان بنفقد حماسنا
Learner B7: فاهمني فهو احنا محددين موضوع تذكر قوي مش مخلينا مثلا نقول
Learner B7: اسبرينت بتمر بمشاكل كذا كذا فإحنا عايزين تشاركونا الحل، فهنا فأنا دلوقتي حاسة الفورم دي أصلا خلينا نشارك أراء وكذا إنما غير كده معين وبعد كده يدخلوا يقولولنا إحنا جايين على حاجة مش مطلوبة برا.
Learner B1: أوكي.
Learner B3: رغم.
Learner B7: أصلا.
Learner B3: عشان كده أنا حاسة بصراحة لو حد بالذات في جديد في المجال هو مش واقعي إن كل 1 يختار التذكرة شغال عليها إذا حد جديد في المجال بجد حاسة مهمة في الأول إن هو يختار حاجة فيها ده رأيي يعني الشخصي.
Learner B7: الحقيقة فاهمة.
Learner B3: أنا في باليدي مبسوطة فدا أكثر.
Learner B1: حلمي وحش يعني.
Learner B3: هو أصعب عامة عايز أقولك نوع أصعب.
Learner B1: لا هو انك تختاري الحاجة اللي إنت بتحبيها ده شيء جميل بس كشغل إنتي مش هيجيلك اللي إنتي بتحبيها.
Learner B3: ما أقدرش هو مش.
Learner B7: البداية بس البداية.
Learner B3: البداية كفيلة يا إما تقفلك يا إما تخليك. حابب الموضوع أوي.
Learner B7: وأنا بصراحة من الناس اللي تقفلت بصراحة.
Learner B1: ما تقوليش كده.
Learner B3: أول مرة في المجال برضه.
Learner B7: أيوة.
Learner B3: أم فهماك.
Learner B7: أنا نزلت قفلت بس كنت متحمسة بأول أسبوع عشان إشتغلنا على مشكلة اللي هي بتاعت كنا بنفهم الأسباب بتاعتها
Learner B7: كان متاح. السبب واضح ما كانش محتاج داتا كبيرة أو إنت تسأل ناس كتير قوي هي على فكرة ممكن تقيس الموضوع على على نفسك
Learner B7: لأن كلنا خدنا كورسات أون لاين إنما تاني مرة كان محتاج داتا كتير جدا واحنا نسأل ناس بس ما كانتش متوفرة خالص إن إنت تسأل ناس وكذا ولا حد بيرد هنا ولا حد برد من فبعد كده قرينا كمان التذكرة غلط أصلا فحسيت ان هو ليه الدنيا صعبة يعني.
Learner B3: أنا عندي مشكلة برضه بس لما عملت عليها انبسطت حسيت إن أنا معايا حاجة أشتغل عليها ففهماكي قوي يعني.
Learner B7: بالظبط.
Learner B3: نسيج الفندق.
Learner B1: طب اختيارات مقتنعين بها ولا في حاجة تتغير.
Learner B5: أنا مريض.
Learner B7: حضرتك أكتر حاجة أخرتك قبل ما تبدأ.
Learner B1: البحث عن المعلومة. دي هي إمم.
Learner B5: ممكن نكمل مع الاختلاف صياغة الطقس ده في.
Learner B1: ممكن ولا شنو.
Learner B5: أيوة ماشي.
Learner B7: ما يمكن لأن عليها بي أر دي فال بي آر دي خاصة مانجر بس هما يكون بيتلهم على طول ثانية خاصة بمجالهم.
Learner B7: ممكن ما أسميش الحاجات بمسمياتها مثلا أيوة
Learner B7: مش عارف هل ده صح؟ ولا لأ طب افتراضي إن كل.
Learner B5: مبروك.
Learner B7: دا بافتراض ال بي آر دي خاص بال برودك مانجرز بس.
Learner B1: والبيورديين ده المفروض كنت تقصدني يا ربي
Learner B1: فكر يعني مش فكرة
Learner B1: أم
Learner B1: كويمنت ما ما اعتقدش ان كل الناس يكون عندهم بي أل دي بس يعني حاجة بتنظم شغلك
Learner B1: بتبين انتي عملتي إيه وما عملتش وفضلك ؟ مش فضللك اياها سلميها إيمتى
Learner B1: عار فنوت من ذلك أمبوي.
Learner B7: بتكلمني أنا ولا بتكلمني.
Learner B1: زيي زي كده تحدد إنت خلصتي إيه و قدامك قد ووقت قد كده طيب ممكن
Learner B1: انت بتروح قد
Learner B7: أيوا صارلك وازبط.
Learner B1: لحظة واحدة.
Learner B3: المحس حالفا.
Learner B1: تمام لما كنت بتوقف أول حاجة كنت تعملها برضو نفس فكرة.
Learner B5: ما تخلي السؤال إن هو يختار كذا اجابة شقة وحدة بس.
Learner B1: ما هو ده هيعمل زيدي هنا. أحجمه بإجابة واحدة بس.
Learner B7: شكرا.
Learner B1: ده.
Learner B7: وكنت بتعرفوا انت كنت بتعملها.
Learner B1: أنا عايز أضيف أم.
Learner B7: هسه سارة أصلا. ما تنضفش يا جماعة سارة مش بتاع أصلا ردت سلطة كوبل.
Learner B1: مفهوم.
Learner B7: فأي اللي بيتساءل بيكون أحمد منصور فقط.
Learner B1: ما هو الاثنين إيه الاثنين إيه.
Learner B7: إنت كنت عايزة الثورة.
Learner B1: يعني اها.
Learner B7: مش اكتب إيه آي طول بقى يعني.
Learner B1: لو صبر القاتل على المقتول كان.
Learner B7: اها.
Learner B1: ما ترومان كول مش مهم طيب
Learner B1: يا له أدي إيه كنت واثق أنك ماشي في ال الاتجاه الصح الغرض من السؤال للجميل دا
Learner B1: إيه لو كان عندهم لو كان عنده مشكلة في
Learner B1: في النضارب مثلا لو حدد المصادر دي ملغبطان أو حدة الطسكي دي ملغبطان هتبان في السؤال ده
Learner B1: والله لو هو متلخبط هيقولك مش عارف إيه مش واثق ما كنتش واثق أو قليل مثلا أو سعيت.
Learner B7: يتزبط في الأول بعد كده تزبط الدنيا يعني.
Learner B1: بالظبط هيبقى خلاص الحتة. دي تعالجت.
Learner B7: لا بس انت كاتب في الاتجاه الصح وانت ماشي خلاص انما الطاسك دي في البداية أصلا وأنا لسه بقرأ
Learner B7: لا ماشي خلاص أنا ما بقيتش اشتغل وماشي في الاتجاه بقى.
Learner B1: ما انتي ما إنت متنكريش؟ إنك في وقت تطرريدي إنك تشتغلي
Learner B1: لمجرد ديدلاين عارفة. بس أنا مش واثقة بعملها.
Learner B7: بالظبط بس إحنا عيني.
Learner B7: بس إحنا بس إحنا مجالنا ممكن يكونوا غير مجالات ناس تانية.
Learner B1: ما هو بالزبط مهو مجالات الناس التانية دول خاصة معاهم كده ولا يبقى مثلا إيه
Learner B1: مانجر اخترتي خلاص التراك ده وحتختاري وهديك مثلا سعادة السؤال ده حتقولي
Learner B1: إيه هتقولي قليل مثلا أو سعيت خلاص كل مثلا دراك الفوليستيك
Learner B1: كلهم قايلين إن لا الدنيا كانت تمام وأنا كنت واثق في اللي هعمله جدا. يبقى المشكلة الموجودة فين.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: انت معايا اليوم.
Learner B7: معاك ايوا معاك بقلك فين.
Learner B1: يبقى مثلا كانت المشكلة في الترانك بتاع برودكت مانجر
Learner B1: ما هو مثلا يبقى معانا كده بتاعتهم كانت صح؟ وكل حاجة كانت واضحة وفي التراك. ال برودكتمال لا مش واضحة.
Learner B7: وده برضو على فكرة ممكن نربطه بمستوى الخبرة يعني مش حيبقى على الإجابة على التراك بس.
Learner B1: مستوى الخبرة.
Learner B7: 3 مع بعض.
Learner B1: ما هو كل ده مربوط.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: مقتنعين ولا شيدوا ولا.
Learner B7: نعم.
Learner B5: لا لا مقتنعين.
Learner B7: الفورم كلها في الآخر يعني.
Learner B1: لو في حاجة كانت موجودة من البداية كنت اوفر عليك وقت قد كانت هي.
Learner B3: أساس.
Learner B7: البيت.
Learner B3: حلو حلو قوي.
Learner B7: سؤال خطير.
Learner B5: في.
Learner B3: يتحط في الأول.
Learner B7: بيجي يوصل لحد البيه.
Learner B3: تحطه في الأول.
Learner B7: اللي أنا عايزها.
Learner B1: بصي بلاش يكتب في الأول خليه يختار يختار يختار بعد كده يكتب.
Learner B3: أنا خايفة يزهقوا بس والله.
Learner B1: ما هي الفورم طويلة الصراحة؟ أنا.
Learner B7: يقسمها على مرتين.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B3: حاسة بصراحة من كتر ما هي طويلة حاسة الناس.
Learner B1: حنحتاج إن إحنا نشيل أسئلة وإحنا كدا مش هنقدر.
Learner B3: أنا حاسة إن إحنا مثلا ممكن نعمل فين بالأسئلة المهمة
Learner B3: وفورم تاني بالأساس مش لازم ينزلوا في نفس الوقت أيوة.
Learner B7: زي ما قلتي مثلا الأسئلة اللي هي هتفرق أوي في اللي إحنا عايزينه وأسئلة مكملة رغم كل إحنا قلناه أساسي مش عارفة.
Learner B3: بس لا حتى في أسئلة.
Learner B5: عندنا في قرارات حاجتين.
Learner B3: طب إحنا ممكن نسأل من الحتة دي عشان.
Learner B1: يعني هو عايزين يعني أنا كان نفسي كل الدين يكون موجود.
Learner B3: هو في ناس كتيرة موجودة النهارده.
Learner B1: ندى ياسر مش معانا مش معنا ياسر
Learner B5: وخرج.
Learner B1: فاقد الشغل خلاص رائعة.
Learner B7: ممكن نخليها
Learner B7: وحدة للنهارده ونبه عليه إن هو يخليها حاجة زي مونتوري كده جدا ولها ديدلاين خاص تخلص النهارده لازم كله يملاها
Learner B7: وبكرا نزلت التانية.
Learner B5: في ناس بتلتهب.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B5: جدي.
Learner B7: هل ممكن نديم قائمة.
Learner B3: حلو.
Learner B7: مثلا هيدولهم تلاتين سنة فيبقى منهم تلاتين ثانية بس.
Learner B1: لي.
Learner B5: يعني.
Learner B1: لك مالك بتعلمين على إيه.
Learner B5: اليوم.
Learner B1: عشوائي.
Learner B7: مش حياخد وقت فعلا فعلا.
Learner B3: هي بس الفكرة الاتنين على فكرة فيهم الحاسة دي برضه ممكن يختار عشوائي لأن هو حيذهب فهي في الآخر.
Learner B1: هو هو أنا بقول إن الأسئلة كثيرة يا جماعة والله بس هو يعني في أسئلة مكررة أو هدي نفس ما إحنا أنا بس عايز.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: يمكن.
Learner B7: بروفا مثلا.
Learner B1: مسؤولوني بس إيه رأيك في ده.
Learner B7: الزي اعتمدت على هسه السؤال مش هيطلعنا حاجة بصراحة.
Learner B1: ليه ليه.
Learner B3: يعني.
Learner B7: ما يطلعنيش بحاجة بصراحة خالص خالص.
Learner B1: أنا لو لو هم مثلا ساعتها اعتمدوا على ثورة مش مهندس أحمد.
Learner B7: لأ لأ إنت كده أنا سوري بجد بس لأ يعني هم مهما أنا قررت أعتمد هم مش حيردوا علي، فأنا أكيد جربت مرة. وما كملتش إذا ده مش إعتماد.
Learner B1: حلو حلم حلو يبقى كده في مشكلة في.
Learner B7: لأ لأ هم هم وظيفتهم مش كده وظيفة سارة أولا سارة ما بتتكلمش في أي حاجة برا إن إنت بتسلم تاسك و ومكونات الطاسك ما بتتكلمش في حاجة أكتر من كده ولا معلومة أي حاجة.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: إذن صار مستبعدا.
Learner B1: ما هو مش ده دور الأدمان مش ده دور مش ولا دور ثارة ولا دور أحمد دورهم إن هم
Learner B1: دورهم إن هم من الآخر يعتبروا إستبدال للمنتور
Learner B1: دورهم إن إنت لو قلت كلمة غلط في ال يعملولك بوست يقولك لا الكلام ده مش صح؟ الكلام الصح.
Learner B7: سكور كرتون بس إنت كده إحنا قصدين على أحمد منصور بس هو فعلا ده.
Learner B1: الاثنين.
Learner B5: طيب.
Learner B7: مش قدمن هي سارة مش قادما أصلا.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B5: لا لا سارة أزمر. لا، لا.
Learner B7: لا مش جورج.
Learner B5: أدمن والله.
Learner B7: الله يسلمك.
Learner B1: نصارى. تعالي هنا. سارة.
Learner B1: أد من هي.
Learner B7: يا جماعة أنا ضدك.
Learner B5: والله سارة أدمن ده لو دخلت.
Learner B7: دايما مكتوب صورة يور مينتو صورة يورمنتور.
Learner B1: سارة انتو شايفين
Learner B1: أي مكتوبة
Learner B1: احدى 10 سنين نوفمبر ما شاء الله أه والحمد لله
Learner B1: موظف مهندس اها.
Learner B7: فعلا مكتوب أدهم.
Learner B1: مين منصور ادمن.
Learner B7: يا جماعة حتى مكتوب سرايورمنتور.
Learner B1: تين.
Learner B7: كان في البداية خالص والله بجد كان تسلمونها مش عار.
Learner B1: أم طب بصي كدا.
Learner B7: الرسالة.
Learner B1: أحمد مرزوق.
Learner B7: مدريد.
Learner B1: أم السلام عليكم.
Learner B7: ما عرفت
Learner B1: على البساطة يعني في
Learner B1: ميش.
Learner B7: أنا أحس إن إحنا طولنا قوي إحنا الساسة وائل.
Learner B1: نحن منغرمهم 100 طب اغيرها لإيه تاني علشان يبقى المقصود بيهم.
Learner B7: أديتها مثلا إنك تسأل إنك تسأل انك تسأل في الشاد بتاع
Learner B7: لأن أكيد لو سألوهم في الدقيقة أكيد ما بيردوش عليهم.
Learner B1: مين ده.
Learner B7: أحمد منصور وسارة.
Learner B1: ليه ليه سارة اعملي التاسك يلا اعملي تيست.
Learner B7: أيوا أدي قلته.
Learner B1: يرد.
Learner B7: بيردوا بأننا بعتمد عليهم في إجابات ومعلومات.
Learner B1: بالظبط يعني أنا ردي يردهم هنا أنا لو سؤال ده ليا تمام أبقى مثلا إيه تقريبا لأ أو قليل
Learner B1: السؤال ده لا.
Learner B7: أنا أعجبتي ما عجبتي. لا.
Learner B1: ليه سعادة أحمد منصور بتاعة التاسك بتاعته كانت بتبقى مفيدة بالنسبة لي.
Learner B7: في فرق بين إن أنا بكلمو في التذكرة بسأله عن لو أنا مش فاهمة حاجة إعتمدت ده معناه إن أنا بسأل الشخص ده كل ما اعتنق حاجة.
Learner B1: خلاص تقريبا لا أحط السؤال ده ولا لأ.
Learner B3: أنا ما في عنا.
Learner B7: مش عارفة مش حاستاهل.
Learner B3: أنا بس مشكلتي إن هو ممكن يكون الناس ما تعتمد عليهم مش لأنهم مش مفيدين لأنهم فعلا يعني مش بجاوبوا على كل حاجة أو شايفينهم فاهمين مش.
Learner B1: ولا كل حاجة يبقى هم مش موفدين فعلا أيوة.
Learner B3: إيه من غير.
Learner B7: فهم كمان مش مخصصين لحاجة معينة.
Learner B3: مثلا ممكن نقول بسؤال ثاني اللي هو أنت حابب يكون في مثلا يعمل حاجة معينة أو كده أو نشير السؤال.
Learner B1: نشيلوا.
Learner B3: أيوه.
Learner B7: مش حساس بصراحة.
Learner B1: بيبون.
Learner B7: إحنا ممكن شايف السؤال لو في حاجة موجودة من البداية كانت تتوفر عليك ممكن بقى نخلي كمان لو في حاجة موجودة معاك في التاسكت حتكون برضه
Learner B7: يعني لو حابب مساعدة يعني ممكن زي موجود في البداية نعمل سؤال شبهه خلال رحلة التاسك دات نفسها.
Learner B1: على جنب لو ما لقناش في البداية.
Learner B7: يعني ممكن تعتبر من البداية ومثلا كمان برضه.
Learner B1: غالبا كنت بتحس بإيه محذم أحط من
Learner B1: انت المطلوب، فهمت؟ لكن بقيت محفوظ أكتر.
Learner B1: وأحتجت.
Learner B3: بس ده يعني رد رده فيدباك يعني.
Learner B1: إن.
Learner B7: صحيح؟
Learner B1: الإي. آي هنا كردوا اللي انا أقصده يعني اللي هو ده.
Learner B7: بردو على فعلا.
Learner B1: ردوا على التوسكة مثلا على.
Learner B7: قدامك ولا على الفيد باك.
Learner B1: حاجة بتوقف قدامي.
Learner B7: كرز.
Learner B7: خلاص حددها في السؤال. أقصد.
Learner B1: أو أي حاجة. ممكن. أعرف.
Learner B5: ممكن بعد رد ال سبرينت أدمن على سؤالك السلام عليكم.
Learner B7: أيوا طبعا لو بسألوك مشكلة واجهتني غير لو هو بيبعتلي فيدباك وأنا برضه فيدباك بتاعي بالنسبة لي ده كافي ووافي ولا لأ أكيد طبعا.
Learner B5: أيوة بالظبط.
Learner B1: لا مش فاهم معلش عشان أنا.
Learner B7: انت دلوقتي لو واجهت مشكلة وانت بتعمل رحت سألت أحمد منصور
Learner B7: حيرد عليك رد أيا كان إيه هو.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: زي مثلا لما يكون رحت تعمل فيدباك وحابب تسأل سؤال ليه علاقة فيدباك دا أرد على التاسك بتاعك.
Learner B7: فطبعا الراديو بالفيد على مشكلة الفيد باكاج إنت أكيد مش محتاج حاجة تانية بعدها أصلا.
Learner B7: انت برده فاهمني ولا لأ.
Learner B1: أنا لما جاني فيدباك وقالي إن إنت حضرت 4 ميتين أنا كنت منهار.
Learner B1: أنا ما حضرت أربعمية أنا حضرت 5 والله كانت خناقة عنيفة.
Learner B7: بالضبط اذا هذه مشكله.
Learner B1: بالظبط.
Learner B1: هو مثلا وأعمله لفوت بقعد.
Learner B7: رسمت المضائق.
Learner B1: أها هل ده كان مفيد ولا بقى يعني.
Learner B7: أنا حاسة بجد إن السؤال اللي ليه علاقة بالإي مش حيفيد أصلا كتير لأن أصلا أصلا
Learner B7: لما دخل معانا في البلانينغ حد وقلنا إن إحنا سألنا حاولنا نسأل لأحمد منصور قال إنتو بتحاول تلعبوا في السيستم وكده لأن هو عارف إن دول مش مفيدين إطلاقا لأي حاجة هم عارفين هو. عارف إن هو الحاجة معينة، فهو مش حتفيدهم أصلا بحاجة
Learner B7: هم في حقيقتهم.
Learner B1: استني يا عمي. استني.
Learner B1: مش كل الناس عارفة تمام دلوقتي يعني إنت قلت مخصصين لحاجة هي الحاجة.
Learner B7: الحاجة اللي هي المساعدة البسيطة.
Learner B1: هم.
Learner B5: جودة.
Learner B1: هي المصادر البسيطة.
Learner B7: يعني مثلا إنت مش عارف الميتينج إمتى يوم هو رد عليكي المتين كذا
Learner B7: كذا لكن ما بناقشش معاك أي حاجة أكتر من كده.
Learner B1: ثانية. وحدة يعني أنت فاكرة يعني إنت شايفة إن هو لما يخش يحضر معنا الميثنغ
Learner B1: ومثلا في حاجة ما تعجبه يروح هو معلق عليها شايفة. إن دي حاجة بسيطة.
Learner B7: آمين.
Learner B5: لأ طبعا.
Learner B1: طيب شفتي يعني مركز في النقطة دي ومش مركز لما أحتاج منك سؤال أو مساعدة.
Learner B7: بالضبط هو إحنا لما بنسأل على بيرد بأي حاجة أصلا.
Learner B1: لا الفكرة.
Learner B7: معلش إنت قصدك هو موجود معنا دلوقتي، صح؟
Learner B1: موجود هو حاسس بينا وسمعنا ما فيش مشكلة تمام ولو حيجيبلك بوسط تحفة تمام
Learner B1: فالفكرة إن إن هو إنت مركز معنا هنا وما شاء الله عليك بتركز هنا أنا مش عايزك مركز هنا وخليك حلو وما فيش مشكلة بس لما أنا أكون مدنوق فعلا وعايز مثلا داتا عايز حضرتك تساعدني الطاسكة دي يعني تقولي إزاي يعني.
Learner B7: فإن.
Learner B1: دي.
Learner B7: وين.
Learner B1: أه.
Learner B7: إنت حكمت عليه. إنت حكمت عليه إنت حكمت مش إنت حكمت عليه من المشكلة بتاعت إن إحنا لما قلنا عايزين نشيل السكور مع بعض هو رد وقال لأ ده ممنوع
Learner B7: انت حكمت عليهم من دي.
Learner B1: لأ مش.
Learner B7: أوامر معينة واخذ أوامر معينة. لو لاقي حاجة بتخالفها بيبعت لكن هو مش بفكر لك في حاجة.
Learner B1: ما تفكرنيش بحاجة ما.
Learner B7: في.
Learner B1: مع السلامة.
Learner B7: أو يحلل لك مشكلة.
Learner B1: لا بصي أنا بالنسبة لي إن هو
Learner B1: زي ما هما بيبعت لنا التوست
Learner B1: و وفاهم ويفضل نشرحلك هتعملها إيه المطلوب فمعلش إنت جزء من من الرحلة دي تمام.
Learner B7: إمم.
Learner B1: ليه لما أنا بطلب ده انك ترفض مثلا
Learner B1: أنا فاهم إن هو واخد أوامر معينة تمام ماشي
Learner B1: تمام بس إنت معلش أنت تعتبر ستيك هولدر
Learner B1: انت 1 من ضمن اللي بتشارك الرحلة معانا فأنا أنا عايز أعرف يعني مثلا لي من حقي إن أنا أعمل مع زينب ومريم مروان إنترفيو أو أسألك.
Learner B3: طيب أنا بس عم.
Learner B7: السلام يا نجوى خلاص طيب يا عمتي.
Learner B3: دلوقتي.
Learner B7: طبعا.
Learner B3: إحنا ممكن نغير السؤال نقوله هل أنت بتشوف لغة الأدمن بالنسبة لك إيه لأن هو كان في ناس فعلا تشتكي من اللغة إن هي صعبة
Learner B3: فأنا ممكن أغير السؤال ده حسب أي سؤال أكتر صراحة ولا رأيكوا إيه.
Learner B1: اللغة دي هي لغة إن العربي.
Learner B3: بتاعته صعبة الفهم.
Learner B7: طريقة كلامه أصلا الصيغة نفسها. ولا قصدك إن هو أصلا.
Learner B3: هو كان في ناس بتقول في صعبة ومثلا لانكوج برضه صعبة أنا حسيت برضه اللانج كان ممكن تبقى كده بالذات في الامتحان الأول خالص.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B3: خلينا نقول يعني.
Learner B1: أكرمها إزاي.
Learner B3: ممكن تقول مثلا شايف لغة ال اللغة المستخدمة من الأضمن
Learner B3: اللغة المستخدمة من أدمن ونحط بقى اختيارات تحت خالي بالك.
Learner B1: ,
Learner B1: اللغة المحتلمة من أد من
Learner B3: بقى نحط اختيارات على طول بقى ممكن نقول
Learner B3: صعبة مثلا و مش بفهم منها قوي الكاسك
Learner B3: صعبة الفهم مثلا وخلاص
Learner B3: مثلا
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي حاجة قبل ما أقولها. هل نحن نخلي ده لوحده ونسأل على السؤال لوحده ولا نجمع في سؤال 1
Learner B3: يعني في ناس ممكن تشوف إن اللغة عادي بس مش كده بس في التكتينز وناس ممكن تشوف إن اللغة كلها على بعضها صعبة.
Learner B7: أمريكي.
Learner B3: آمين فاطمة خديت سؤالين أنا حسب بوين دي بصراحة مهمة
Learner B3: لأن هذه ممكن تخلي يعني الناس ما تعرفش تعمل.
Learner B7: مش فاماكي قصدك عيبروس.
Learner B3: إنت إنت قلتي مش فهمي أنا سمعتها فهماكي
Learner B3: إن إحنا نخلي سؤال ليه علاقة باللغة ممكن الناس مش مشكلتها في في على أد ما مشكلتها في اللغة نفسها. وفي ناس
Learner B3: ممكن تشوف إن اللغة تمام بس المستخدمة هي اللي صعبة أوي فاهمة قصدي إيه.
Learner B1: يعني.
Learner B7: إنت قصدك إن هو بيتكلم معايا كلام عادي.
Learner B7: هو تمام بيكلمني في حاجة لها علاقة تمام.
Learner B3: لا، لا، اللي هو.
Learner B1: له.
Learner B3: أنا قصدي.
Learner B1: بي ار دي ده فهمتيها ولا حضرتك انك تدوري عليها.
Learner B3: وهل.
Learner B7: متواجد.
Learner B3: لا بس هل ما فهمتهاش عشان ال صعبة ولا عشان هي مستخدمة فيها صعبة
Learner B3: مش قصدي مش قصدي اللغة قصدي ترانز ليها علاقة أو الفيل نفسه هيبقى صعب.
Learner B7: أيوا إحنا تقريبا سايرين السؤال ده فوق
Learner B7: سؤال شبهه يعني تسأليني السؤال ده شبهه فوق اللي هو لما حطينا اللغة في الاختيارات.
Learner B3: فبس كان واضح يعني أو في ستريس على موضوع اللغة.
Learner B7: طبعا ما كانش بيه ستريس بس حسيت ان هي
Learner B7: يعني كان بالنسبة لي لو أنا شفتها كان ممكن اختارها عادي وأحس ان هو
Learner B7: كافي بس لو حسيت ممكن أعمل ستريس تمام.
Learner B3: أبحث الصراحة.
Learner B7: ممكن.
Learner B3: لأن في كذا حد قال عن الموضوع ده إحنا ممكن نقول ممكن سهلة ولكن صعبة مثلا ممكن نحطها من ضمن الإختيارات.
Learner B1: وأنا لو طلبت طلب منكم.
Learner B1: أنا تركيدي أنا عايز طلب 1 بس ممكن يعني
Learner B1: تشوف ال فورم دي الأول أنا حروح أوضح النهاردة فمش كل الناس كانت معانا والناس.
Learner B5: أيلول.
Learner B1: عشان تراجع الفوق أنا بس أعد حاجة وحدة
Learner B1: إن كلكم تشوفوا الفورم حبعتهالكوا كلكم تشوفوها و
Learner B1: وشوفوا إيه الأسئلة اللي مش مقتنعين بيها الأسئلة اللي مش فاهمينها تاني
Learner B1: إيه الأسئلة اللي عايز أردها.
Learner B3: أنا عايزة أزود حاجة بس يا ريت كلنا نشوف إيه أهم الأسئلة ونتفق عليها وتبقى أهم 10 أسئلة.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B3: ماشي.
Learner B1: تمام وإيه و و
Learner B1: فاهمين حاجة.
Learner B3: أيوة أيوة تمام تمام.
Learner B1: تمام هناك بقى ماشي.
Learner B3: خلاص ماشي أوكي.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B1: أنا كل حاجة عينيك محلش يدي.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B1: يعني أخدت الجمل تاعك.
Learner B3: لا، أنا.
Learner B3: ، ماشي.
Learner B1: تمام مسلوب.
Learner B1: شكرا أنا شاكر عن تركيا.
Learner B3: طيب خلاص.
Learner B1: دي الأسئلة ثانية وحدة
Learner B1: دي الأسئلة اللي جمعتها من الشيك انتو شايفنها لأ.
Learner B3: امم.
Learner B1: معرفش في حاجة في التاني.
Learner B3: انت ممكن تحطهم على مثلا غوغل دوكس وتشير اللينك أنا ممكن أبقى أزود برضه لا.
Learner B1: ا تمام أنا هعمل كل حاجة هينه.
Learner B1: أيه فين
Learner B1: ماشي ثانية واحدة.
Learner B3: أنا بس عندي سؤال يعني برا الموضوع هو إنتو بعتلكوا غلط ازاي أو إنتو. كنتوا فاهمين الموضوع إزاي.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: أنا تعرفت على إحنا نشتغل على مشكلة
Learner B7: مشكلة إن إحنا لما نعمل كذا فروميشن للتاستك
Learner B7: يبقى في عدد كبير بيوصل للمنتر فكدا المنتر بيبقى عنده ضغط فال فايدباك يوصل متأخر
Learner B7: فال موتيفيشن بتاعنا يقل فدي المشكلة واحنا نناقشها وكده فلما دخل معانا أحمد إيه
Learner B7: دخل معنا في الينج وقلنا له ندي المشكلة نحلها قال ده لا ده مش ده المطلوب يعني تذكر بعتركه بطريقة مش ده المطلوب تشتغلوا عليه
Learner B7: هو قال لنا كدا.
Learner B3: أم أوكي.
Learner B1: معلش ثانية وحدة بالزبط.
Learner B3: لا براحتك
Learner B3: هو برضه أداني فيدباك أنه أنا المفروض أقولها لازم أسأل أكتر ليه هي جت يعني أو أنا يعني ليه تعملت بالطريقة دي فبصراحة نورني.
Learner B1: ا.
Learner B3: مش بس هو مثلا لقيت دلوقتي مكتوب في بلانينغ إنه دائما. طب أنا أفهم هم ليه بوينت بتاعتهم أصلا هم من كذا فيرجين
Learner B3: من سبينس نفسهم بصراحة فبجمع أسئلة دلوقتي إن أنا أبعتها يعني.
Learner B1: أهاه مرة واحدة.
Learner B3: إنتو مبسوطين في انتيرشيب.
Learner B7: و40 شوية.
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B7: كده فجأة.
Learner B1: آيدرس.
Learner B3: أنا مش قادمة.
Learner B7: أسيل لما كنت بتقولي المشاكل حاسة صلبة صوباني فجأة.
Learner B3: لا، لا، لا، وحذروا مني بقى.
Learner B1: مساء الخير
Learner B1: فانيللا
Learner B1: ورقة عمل
Learner B1: أنا حقولك على حاجة إنتي ممكن تسألي السؤال بطريقة تانية قاليهم قلهم لو في الآخر خالص
Learner B1: لما لما تعرضوا لما نعرض برودكت لو جاكم فرصة إنكم تقرروا الإنترنت
Learner B1: تحبون تذكروا زي ما هي ولا.
Learner B7: أكيد هيكون فاتح إنت قصدك.
Learner B1: وحشة.
Learner B7: إنت بقيت تسعمية إنت كمان مع بعض.
Learner B3: إيه.
Learner B1: جنيه وأحسن.
Learner B3: إيه جماعة الصعبة في السؤال يعني عادي إحنا تيم وبنعرف بعض السؤال.
Learner B5: نحن مترقبين.
Learner B7: التأمين على فكرة.
Learner B3: أكيد.
Learner B7: أنا مرة سألت على السكورز بتاعت التيم فجأة خرجت
Learner B7: والله ما أخدتش ثواني فجأة اللواء أحمد منصور بات محدش.
Learner B1: ا.
Learner B7: يذكروا طمع حد اللي هو إنت إنت عارف الزاي.
Learner B3: ، أوكي.
Learner B7: من.
Learner B1: سمير.
Learner B7: متسابقين عادي.
Learner B3: فكرة أنا حاسة إن إحنا يعني ممكن شير بوينتس هتفتح لنا حاجات في التاسك نفسه
Learner B3: يعني مش لازم يعني نقولها بشكل عام فاهمة.
Learner B7: إنت قصدك أصلا نحنا كأننا مثلا بالنسبة لنفسنا.
Learner B3: يعني أنا مثلا عاجبني أصلا شغالة في التاسك ده إن أنا في حاجات وأنا ماشية فيها بلحظها على نفسي مش لازم بقى أبعث فيدباك أو كده فده.
Learner B1: ما هو حقولك على حاجة بقى ما أنا حقولك على حاجة إنت مش مش مفروض يعني تعتمدي على نفسك. أهوائك إنت مشاكلك انتي
Learner B1: مش يعني إيه مش لازم تكون هي المشاكل اللي عند كل الناس.
Learner B3: دا كدا.
Learner B7: أنا كنت بحسب كدا فعلا طلع اللي هو الشخص مفروض يشتغل بأرقام مش مش بأحاسيس حتى أي فيدباك كان بيوصلني منها بسكور قليل كان دائما كل كلامها إن فين الداتا فين الأرقام مش مش حاجة وحدة اللي بتقوليها.
Learner B3: ده كلام صح 1,000,000 في المية بس دي بتاعتي بوينت بتاعتي إن أنا لما أعمل دي الوقت على حاجة وأنا عايشة برضه معاهم في نفس الحاجة ببقى فاهمة يعني أنا لما حد بيقول مثلا الناس بتقول أو كده أنا فاهمة جايين منين غير إن أنا أكون قاعدة ومش حاسة أو مش في نفسها فاهمة قصدي.
Learner B7: أيوة إنت قصدك إنتي شغالة على حاجة إنت أصلا عيشاها.
Learner B3: بالضبط بالضبط مش معناه إن أنا أعتمد على أحسيسي بس يعني كان كل 1 عنده 1,000,000.
Learner B7: شكرا. تسلم تسلم تسلم.
Learner B5: أنا بقول نقفل علشان أحمد منصور دلوقتي هيبعت لنا يقول كفاية كده يا جماعة.
Learner B3: هو إنت غلبان الأول كنا ببقى كويت كده ستاند أب إنتو قد
Learner B7: هو الأول كان يبقى ربع ساعة احنا كنا بنطول لساعة دلوقت ساعة دلوقتي إحنا معديهاش ساعتين.
Learner B1: على حسب مستوى الجهل تعمل على حسب.
Learner B7: يعني.
Learner B3: حكومات.
Learner B3: إمم.
Learner B1: أم أم.
Learner B3: يا ترى تيم ميتينغز.
Learner B7: عفوا بكيت كتير هو أصلا أنا.
Learner B1: على فكرة اللي يطول ده مش صح؟ معلومات.
Learner B3: مش عارف حصل حاجة.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B3: ما شاء الله.
Learner B1: مساحة.
Learner B7: على فكرة كل 1 لو كان خد الفورم لوحده كان حياخذ فيها وقت عادي جدا.
Learner B1: كريم غسيل خليل.
Learner B3: إحنا لسه تقريبا جدد في الفيلد
Learner B3: كل ما نحنا ناخد وقتنا يعني.
Learner B1: بشم.
Learner B3: طيب هو انت بتعمل حاجة معينة.
Learner B1: حقه.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: نحن مستنين إيطالي.
Learner B3: أنت لو حابب.
Learner B1: حيلا حيلا هيلا ممكن بس
Learner B1: امم فين ال
Learner B1: أم
Learner B1: أها
Learner B1: ممكن تأكدوا علي كدا تمام ولا لأ.
Learner B7: محيط
Learner B1: الفرن وصلت على الجميل.
Learner B5: مايوز.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B3: أنا لو حبيت أزود في الدوكيمنت هل نستنى بكرة وأبقى.
Learner B1: ولا قعدت.
Learner B3: ولا
Learner B1: دش مهندس.
Learner B1: أم
Learner B1: مرحبا.
Learner B7: طيب ممكن سؤال بقى ممكن سؤال.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: دلوقتي شغالين على بروتوتي تايب معين خاص بقى اللي إحنا عملناه في الأسبوع اللي فاتوا عشان نحنا أي حاجة عملناه في الأسبوع اللي فات
Learner B7: تمام في دلوقتي حاسه ان احنا بعدنا شوية إحنا بقينا شغالين على مشاكل سبينت يعني
Learner B7: بشكل عام كده أكتر وبنحلها مش مشكلة بيتسلم وفي بيوصل وحماس بيقل صح.
Learner B3: سبرينت بشكل عام. لأ أنا حاسة إن إحنا.
Learner B7: أيوة. أقصد نفسها بشكل عام يعني مش اللي هو إحنا بنسلم فعددهم كتير بيقل فاحنا عايزين حل للموضوع ده إذا المشكلة. ما بقتش؟ هنا؟ المشكلة؟ بقت مشاكل التدريبات نفسها.
Learner B3: ما أنا حاسة إن كل ده بيؤدي فاهمة قصدك إحنا ممكن نحط فعلا أسئلة يعني نقول أكثر اللي بقلل حماسك اللي مش عارفة إيه.
Learner B7: لا، أنا أقصد أقول كده لما دخل معانا بعيد عن المطلوب، وإنه غلط نوعا ما فأنا عايز أفهم دلوقتي.
Learner B1: خلينا.
Learner B7: فأنا دلوقتي لما أروح أعمل بروتوتيب دلوقتي أنا دلوقتي دلوقتي أنا اشتغلت عالبروتو تايب وعملتو بحيث إنه يكون في حاجة لها علاقة بالفوميشن والكلام من ده الوقت بتحاسب على الفورم دي إننا بشتغل على مشاكل وبنحاول نحلها مع بعض، نحاول نطلع إكسبيرنس حلوة ليهم في المرة الجاية
Learner B7: مش مش مجرد تاسك وموتيفيشن فقط يعني حاجة صغيرة جوا ال تينتشر
Learner B7: إحنا كمان بنتكلم على مشكلة فهم الطازك ومشكلة ان هو يبدأ بسرعة في الطاس يسلم ازاي
Learner B7: تفاصيل فهماني من اول ما اشترك لحد دلوقتي
Learner B7: إحنا بقينا نتكلم كرحلة كاملة ما بقيناش لينا علاقة اللي انبعت لنا على سيركل وعلى
Learner B7: أنا بقيت حاسة. إنه أشتغل دلوقتي خصوصا إني تقال على التوسك اللي احنا شاغلين عليه ألريدي من الأسبوع اللي فات. إنه هو غلط
Learner B7: وإن الفورم دي هي الحاجة اللي كان مفروض نفكر فيها إن إحنا لما نلاقي حاجة زي دي لا نكبر دماغنا ونكبر مداركنا ونكبر أفكارنا ونحاول نشوف المشاكل بجد وندور أكثر،
Learner B7: فأنا بقيت حاسه انه.
Learner B1: لا هو معلش ما تقلديش نفسك في النقطة دي هو الفكرة إن الباسكت بانت غلط اللي.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: يعني هو الفكرة إن هو إيه هي يعني مش أنا برضه اللي بقول كده حتى كان رأي ندى إن هي من وجهة نظرها. إن كدا كدا النقطة دي معملها بريديشن فأنا أشتغل عند بيديش
Learner B1: والنقطة إن أنا أشكك في موضوع النفس. أنا قلته مبارح فهميني.
Learner B7: رغم.
Learner B3: اللي إنتو إشتغلتوا عليها على فكرة غالت قوي ما دي برضه تعتبر.
Learner B1: من.
Learner B7: بس جزء من جزء من ضمنها أسئلة كل الأسئلة في الفورم دي ما تخدمش الحتة دي خالص.
Learner B1: قبل.
Learner B7: تنشك تفجرني كملك.
Learner B3: عندك حق أنا حاسة
Learner B3: حاسة ممكن نزود أسئلة ليها علاقة أكتر سبيسيفيكمنت حاسة ممكن أقعد أفكر فعلا في أسئلة كدا واحنا كلنا نفكر.
Learner B7: ماشي بس حتى لو فكرنا هو اتقللنا التذكرة غلط، فأنا عايز أعرف أكمل من أنهي اتجاه يعني حتى لو حتى لو فكرنا هو تقللنا لا ده التاسك ده كان غلط مش دي المشكلة بالظبط لأ يا جماعة فكروا في حاجة تانية بالنص بجد أنا تفاجئت
Learner B7: تفاجئت. بصراحة، هو أنا دلوقتي مش عارفة أكمل بروتوتي طيب على أساس إيه لمين.
Learner B1: اها.
Learner B7: عندي مشكلة.
Learner B1: كان باين من طريق كلامه في الأول
Learner B1: هو ما كانش يعني أول ما دخل معنا مكنش بيتكلم في حتة
Learner B1: الفيد باك بيوصل متأخر ده هو كان بيك.
Learner B7: أيوا حسيته مستني مننا إن إحنا نحل مشكلة واجهناها جوا ونحل المشكلة وندي فيدباك ونعمل مش عارف حسيته مستني مننا ده ما لقاش ده يعني قل حماس من ناحيتنا شوية فأنا تفاجئت يعني إنت مش بتكلمنا في الحتة بتاعتنا أصلا
Learner B7: فعشان كده أنا كنت عارفة اتكلم بصراحة في
Learner B3: أنا أنا حاسة بس إن هو أهم حاجة تفرق إن إحنا نجيب يعني حاسة دي أكتر حاجة فارقة معاهم.
Learner B7: أنا فاهمة. أنا فاهمة قصدك. بس أقصد، أقول حتى لو أنهي مشكلة بالزبط دلوقتي عايزة بقى يبقى المشكلة تحطلي هل مشكلة فيدباك وال موتيفيشن ولا مشكلة الجيرني أصلا بمشاكلها اللي إحنا عملناها الفورم دي.
Learner B3: اللي أنا ماشية عليها أنا ماشية على حسب اللي أنا عملتو يعني على إن أنا جمعتها بأكثر ناس بتقول نفس المشكلة
Learner B3: أو في أوبشن كان بوتين كده فال كومنت عليه كذا فود فكنت وبحط ليه يعني ما هوش.
Learner B7: أها أنا كمان صرت ألمانيا.
Learner B3: كنت بقولك بس إن هو موضوع أكثر حاجة أركز عليها فده معناه، أوتوماتيك دي أكتر حاجة بتعطل الناس.
Learner B7: ماشي دلوقتي انت شغالة ليه لأن إنت دلوقتي دماغك متبرمجة لأن هي تشتغل على إيه على مشاكل إنترنت صح.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: دلوقتي برمجة على ده احنا دلوقتي كنا نشتغل على بتاع ال ويك ثري
Learner B7: مرة طازك تاني على الفيد بوك لما يسلم يعني ففي حاجات بتبقى مخصصة قوي حاجة مخصصة جدا.
Learner B7: حاجة حاجة لو أنا حسيت إن شخص عامل ريتر عشان ياخد مني فيدباك، فأنا حكون شايفة. إنه هو بياخدها عشان خاطر يشتغلها عليها على نفسه يشتغلها. هم كناس مسؤولين عن مش مستانين مني أشتغل. على ده
Learner B7: أنا مكنتش حاسة التوجيه. ده يخليني أفكر زي ما إنت عملتي إنت لما عملتي؟ ده أنا قلت أكيد إنتو كنت شاغلو حاجة تانية خالص التذكرة مختلفة، فاهماني
Learner B7: فأنا مش عارفة أنا بتكلم صح أصلا ولا أنا فعلا يعني برضه فأنا مش عارفة.
Learner B3: فاهمة قصدك قوي قوي بس أنا حاسة إن إنت ما تحوليش تبصيها كأنها حاجات منفصلة حاولي تضفيها إزاي. أنا أربط التلاتة ببعض حتى لو إنت إشتغلتوا على تلاسك إنت ممكن تبقي شايفة إن هي غلط
Learner B3: بس أنت ممكن تحاولي توظفيها في الأوفر أل فيو يعني مثلا لما دخلت ال ميتينج؟ أنا ما كنتش عارفة ولا عاملة حسابي إن أنا حاخد منه أو كده أنا جاتلي الفكرة وأنا فيه
Learner B3: وعلى فكرة ده أدى برضه إن أنا عملت تاسك مختلف عن مفروض أعمله في تيم بتاعي بس.
Learner B7: بالزبط اللي أنا بتكلم فيه إنت عملتي بوك مختلف عشان إنت.
Learner B1: معلش لما بعثت لل إي آي قالت
Learner B7: بالزبط وده اللي بتكلم فيه بقى طب ما إنت في الآخر هتسلمي طازك معين للإي بكريتريا معينة بشوية أوت كامبز وهو مستنيها شوية حاجات مستنية تكوني ماشية عليها وتسلميها.
Learner B7: إن إنت فكرتي فيه ده وحاولتي إن إنت تعمليه ده حاجة ممكن تكون أنا قدمها بشكل منفصل المسؤولين عنها بعد بقولهم يا جماعة أنا عملت ده إشتغلت ده ليكوا
Learner B7: إنما دلوقتي لما أجي أروح أقول ال إي آي إيه دي المشكلة اللي اشتغلت عليها وده مش اللي هو ملتزم بيه في التعليمات بتاعته ما هو كده مش هيديني سكور لأن دي مش المشكلة
Learner B7: فاهمة قصدي طيب ولا
Learner B3: فاهمة قصدك بجد قوي بس أنا بصراحة أنا بالنسبة لي هي بالنسبة لي ده اللي مهم في الآخر زي ما إنتي بتقولي هو معين على فكرة حتى تقال كده كان في حاجة معناها يعني إن إنتو خلوا في رولز وكل حاجة بس ده ما يوقفكوش إن أو كده
Learner B3: فأنا مش بمشي بالورقة والقلم بصراحة
Learner B3: بس أنا مش بقول صح أو غلط أنا بقول أنا بمشي ده أنا كمريم يعني.
Learner B1: قالك
Learner B7: بالظبط.
Learner B3: اداني فيدباك وداني على فكرة سكور يعني هو قالوا ما بيدوش سكور بس أنا أخدت سكور في الآخر.
Learner B1: ما كلنا خدنا سكور.
Learner B7: هو غادة أول مرة.
Learner B1: ودك تكون ثاني.
Learner B3: وفي ثاني مرة برضه.
Learner B7: مرة اداني سكور بس هو بعتهولي بشكل منفصل ما بعتوليش في الأول في أول مرة.
Learner B1: أيوه عندك.
Learner B3: هو كان الداني. أنا مش عارفة هو عادي.
Learner B1: هيدي أيدي مش.
Learner B3: ثري بوينت ناين من فايف.
Learner B3: وقال لي وقال لي إن هو كان الأوفر فيو حلو أوفر أول بس هو تقريبا يعني على حسب ما فكره إن أنا أديك يعني ديبر كده في في نفس أكتر وكده.
Learner B7: أيوا هو اداني فيدباك. حلو أداني فور بوينت ثري من فاير.
Learner B3: يا هلا.
Learner B7: وأن فور بوين ثري.
Learner B1: يمين.
Learner B7: بس ده في البرينت اللي فات بس قالي إن أنا مشكلتي في حتة إن الحتة اللي بعد كده طلعت برنتو مش شغال عليها بشكل قوي زي سبرينت ون
Learner B7: ده اللي كان ناقص يعني اللي كان ناقص إن أنا كنت أركز قوي في ال في الرايس ومش عارف زي ما أنا فكرت إن أنا الحاجات دي برضه كان أول مرة أتعرضلها أول مرة فاهمين الرايس أول مرة فاهمين مش عارف كذا
Learner B7: مش مركزة فيها.
Learner B1: مراقب.
Learner B3: رغبة.
Learner B1: ميني فور بوينت ايت.
Learner B3: طب حلو حلو.
Learner B7: فتح.
Learner B1: فظيع مش مقتنع.
Learner B7: مش مقتنع وأنا مش مقتنع.
Learner B3: مقتنعين.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: هو أنا مش مقتنع مش فاهمة مش مقتنع ليه طيب يعني.
Learner B1: ما أنا بقول لك هو الفكرة يا جماعة ماشي الرد على الكلمة برضه الرد على فيدباك بيتأخر
Learner B1: هي تكون مشكلة بس مش هي دي المشكلة اللي تخليني أتجاهل باقي المشاكل اللي بجد ممكن تطفش باقي الناس وأركز على المشكلة دي.
Learner B7: بالزبط مديك حاجة تخليك أصلا أو يديك حاجة تخليك أصلا. تفكر في الحتة دي مديك هاند تخليك أصلا إنت تقول لأ لأ ده أكيد دي مش المشكلة
Learner B7: فهمني.
Learner B1: الكلام.
Learner B7: هو مش بيقولك إن الناس مش بيقولك إن الناس مش هم انترنشن فإحنا نعتقد إن المشكلة في في لا هو بيديك مديك فعلا. إنه هو حماسه.
Learner B1: نعم.
Learner B7: بسبب.
Learner B1: مش لدرجة إن حماس.
Learner B7: بالضبط هو.
Learner B1: ا.
Learner B7: وعلى فكرة الموضوع كان مركز أكتر من ناحية الينترز أكثر من من على فكرة
Learner B7: الموضوع كان مركز إن هم الوقت بياخد معهم، كتير قوي فإنت محتاج تعمل تشوف طريقة هم يخليهم هما زي ما يكون يسهل معهم التصحيح يسهل معاهم مراجعة أكثر. فالمشكلة كانت مركزة عليهم أكثر،
Learner B7: فأنا كنت حاسة ما فيش حاجة فعلا تخليني. أفكر في الإنترنيشن زي ما مريم ما شاء الله عملت وإنها فكرت في الموضوع بشكل أوسع فرحت وركزت إنها تشوف مشاكلهم وتحل بشكل ما كانش في هينتال ده.
Learner B1: أو.
Learner B7: ممكن فعلا كون أنا غلطان في أي حاجة.
Learner B1: لو فكره لو فاكرة خالص لو فكرة يا جماعة هو معقولة سألت لما جاتلي إنت قلت هو معقولة يا جماعة فكرة إن هو
Learner B1: إيه في بينك بيفهم متأخر يعني تخلي الواحد يمشي أنا مش شايفها مشكلة ده من منظوري. أنا.
Learner B7: هو ما قالش يمشي وقال حماسه يقل بس.
Learner B1: أو حماسته، ما زرتش دللي.
Learner B7: أم.
Learner B1: إيه.
Learner B3: مش حاسس إن فيدباك بيتأخر.
Learner B7: هو بقى لما قلنا كده إحنا قلنا أن السرفي اللي إحنا ما وصلش معينة ولا وصل لنتيجة هو قال لنا لأ لأ مش كان بيشتغلوا عليها. لا شك غلط خالص
Learner B7: الرد كان كده يعني ما قاللناش مثلا لأ كان مفروض تفكروه بشكل تاني لا مجهود بشكل غلط.
Learner B1: متين.
Learner B3: أنا عايزة أقولكم أصلا هو لما قال لي في الأول قال لي إنت عاملة تمام بس إنت ال جروب تاني أنا أنا ما فهمتش ما فهمتش أصلا إن هو في جروب تاني واخدين تاسك ثاني إفتكرت أصلا أنا بجد فهمت غلط تماما بس.
Learner B7: وأنا كنت عارفة.
Learner B1: إنت عارفة إن التذكرة اصلا مكتوب كده.
Learner B3: أنا كنت فاكرة إن ده مش.
Learner B1: حتى والله الأسماء يعني كويس أنت مش لوحدك.
Learner B3: عداد يعني.
Learner B1: أه.
Learner B7: ما تجيش بالي منها بصراحة.
Learner B1: مين إيه.
Learner B3: هو أنا كده لو حبيت أزود أسئلة أزود على طول على الفورم.
Learner B7: مش عمل. أكتيڤ.
Learner B1: لا، لا، أنا عامل من ديكو كله فأكثر.
Learner B7: إزاي. أنا لما مليتها كشخص طبيعي
Learner B7: كشخص يعني بيملي بيانات وبيحطلك داتا وكده.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B7: فما أدانيش أكسس.
Learner B1: لأ هو أنا بتكلم على الفورم الجديدة.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B1: أوتريك.
Learner B1: لا، أنت لو فتحتيها تلاقي.
Learner B7: بالنسبة لجمال حتة الطاستك ممكن يبقى غلط وكدا أنا أصلا في اليوم ده لما بعثت في الشكل الرئيسي. قلت إنه
Learner B7: إن الموضوع ده مش مشكلة إن إحنا كده أصلا مش ملاحظين الحماس بيه اللي عندنا فإما المشكلة مش موجودة جوا سبرينت أصلا
Learner B7: يا إما إنتو بتقيسوا الموضوع ده على أي بلاد فورم تانية، فأنا لو هاجي جيت أجيب من برا مش أجيب سبرينت المشكلة مش موجودة عند سبرانت لقيت أحمد منصور راجل بيقول لأ إلتزموا بالتعليمات وكذا ده كان رده
Learner B7: فبقيت حاسة لأ كده المشكلة موجودة ولا ما عملتش سلبية على ناس كتير فهمني.
Learner B1: غلطانة إزاي تعتمدي على حاجة زي كده.
Learner B7: أنت فاهم قصدي أصلا.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B7: دلوقتي إنت إنت فعلا زي ما انت قلت لأ أنا حسيت إن فعلا ال يقل عشان خاطر ال فيد باكيت بعد متأخر
Learner B7: دي حاجة تافهة قوي إن البني آدم يمشي والكلام من ده صح حسيتهاش مشكلة،
Learner B7: فأنا لما كتبت في ال بعت بعثت دول قلت إنه إن المشكلة دي مش موجودة في سبرانت أصلا لأن الفيد بيوصل بسرعة عادي مش بيوصل بطريقة تخلي الناس يفوضوا حماسهم ويمشوا يعني مش بيوصل بالأسبوع مثلا لأ وبعد ساعتين بيكترها، كذا فالمشكلة أصلا مش موجودة جوا ال برينت فإما إنتو قصدتكو
Learner B7: إن إنتو تعملوا المشكلة دي لبلاد فورمز تانية
Learner B7: ودي مشكلة عايزين إحنا نشتغل عليها أصلا بوجه عام يا إما هي موجودة جوا برنت بس ال بس إحنا بتاعتنا ضيقة قوي
Learner B7: في أي حاجة من التنين قالي. لا إلتزمي بالتعليمات بتاعة التاسك يعني حتى ما لقيتنيش في الموضوع ولا تذكر غلط ولا فعلا مش دي لا قال لي إلتزمي بتعليمات التاسك.
Learner B1: علشان هو من ربع العالي.
Learner B7: شايف انت قلت اي نوع كان قصدي أرسل.
Learner B1: على شنو هو.
Learner B7: يخليك إن إنت تشتغل أكتر وإن لما يوصلك كلمة في البلانغ تذكر غلط تخليك ت تحس إن إنت كنت مغيب مثلا
Learner B7: أو تحس إن إنت كنت غلطان يعني الإجابة تحسك إن إنت ما اشتغلتش كفاية مش تحسك إن الغلط من عندهم.
Learner B1: هو كان الرد ينفع من المهندس أحمد.
Learner B1: تمام.
Learner B1: أما الفكرة لما يعني كنا ما نحاولش نتناقش
Learner B1: هو هو إحنا مش بنغلط إحنا كل حاجة صح؟
Learner B1: حقولك حاجة إنت جربيه تبعتي أي داتا هبلان تمام من كذا قال لي في أي حاجة تمام.
Learner B7: يمكن.
Learner B1: ما هو غير كده اطلبي منه. إنك تعدلي على الدانة. دي
Learner B1: أنا بس محتاجة أعدل عندي الأصلية دي بالشكل الفلاني الفلاني شوفي هيقولك إيه.
Learner B7: عندي.
Learner B3: اللي.
Learner B7: نعم.
Learner B3: هو أنتم مثلا، هل جاء لكم فيدباك مثلا معين مختلف تماما من يعني سواء مثلا سواء أحسن أو مش أحسن
Learner B3: أو مختلف.
Learner B7: فراغ حاجة واحمد حاجة.
Learner B7: أنا قصدك.
Learner B3: ده برضه في الفورم بس عايزة أسألكوا يعني.
Learner B1: لا التنين متفقين مع بعض.
Learner B1: من أين يجب علي.
Learner B7: إمم هو قليل لما أحمد أصلا يبعت فيدباك على فكرة.
Learner B1: بحيث.
Learner B3: ردت الراتو.
Learner B7: مايو.
Learner B3: إنه في في مثلا مختلف على ال إي آي جيند.
Learner B7: إنت قصدك لأن هالشخص بيدخل معانا الرتر اصلا.
Learner B1: مشينا معاكم.
Learner B1: لا ما هو ده ده اللي حصل معانا مش مش بالشكل أنت اللي حصل معانا في المهندس أحمد حاول يتكلم معانا كشكل في الرتر يعني
Learner B1: هو كان بيتكلم بوجهة نظره اللي هو كان محضرها تمام واحنا بنتكلم بالتسكي اللي احنا عملناها واللي جات لنا
Learner B1: هو من طريقة كلامه كان بيقول كان بيتكلم بطريقة عامة قوي يعني مش هي دي الطريق مش هي دي مش مش مناسبة ما اللي إحنا عملناه
Learner B1: فأنت كمان ما عرضتش عنهم سواء فكرة إيه إيه.
Learner B3: أنا متأصلة فيه. باكس كوربس أنا باك اللي هو فكري يعني أيوة أيوة
Learner B3: بس قصدي الفكر نفسه أو أيا كان طريقة الفيدباك متماشية مع.
Learner B7: أنا بصراحة مش برا فرق بين الوقت فأنا مش حقدر أفتكر بس أنا فاكرة. إن آخر حاجة دخلناها اللي هي كانت مبارح. تقريبا
Learner B7: كان علينا التذكرة غلط وكدا فالموضوع كان ماشي أسئلة
Learner B7: في مرة تانية كان في بياخد منها فيدباك بس كان بياخد فيدباك على الانترنت
Learner B7: من منظورنا إحنا كنت تحبوا إن نحنا نضيف كنت تحبوا نحنا كذا بس وكان بيدي فيد وكان ناقشنا في المشكلة اللي احنا فكرنا فيها في الطاس الأول
Learner B7: ودنافيد باك لكل 1 طريقة تفكيروا في ال كاس كانت عاملة ازاي انا جرحت شخصيته عاملة ازاي بس مش أكتر يعني ما عشناش حاجة أكتر من كده.
Learner B3: يعني بس ما إن هو غلط أو حاجة ده كان قصدي إن هو كان في ممكن المرضي اختلاف شوية.
Learner B7: لأ الإيجانت لأ هو كأن الشخص اللي دخل معانا مبارح ما يعرفش أصلا التزكر إيه هو تقريبا ما قرأوش هو مفكرو. إن هو حاجة معينة وال إيجنت متبرمج على حاجة معينة.
Learner B3: أوكي تمام حاسه بس ممكن.
Learner B1: مشعل.
Learner B7: حاسة أنا دلوقتي تريب من برا ومن جوا.
Learner B3: كمان.
Learner B1: أو.
Learner B3: طبعا منقول اسرار يعني حتى لا.
Learner B7: قصد كدا
Learner B7: مش قصدي كده مبهورة من ساعة ما لقيت كنت أسأل على العادل على السكور بتاعه ندى وخرجت لقيت حد بيقولي ما تسألش على سكور، فأنا نسيتها مش عارفة.
Learner B1: مني يا مريم أنا أنا بجد يعني الإعلانات تاعت اللي كانت عن كانت مختلفة خالص على أنا دخلت
Learner B1: أنا بنيت إكسبيشن من الماركتينغ اللي عملوها
Learner B1: ولما دخلت دحلقت حليقة وحشة تمام
Learner B1: عادي نخسر إيه ثاني حاجة وتاني حاجة من كتر يعني ده أول حاجة تاني حاجة
Learner B1: انا من ضمن الحاجات اللي كنت معجب قوي في وخلصت
Learner B1: حخش بقى وايه يعني من درجة عايز تمام
Learner B1: سألت سألت عن برودكت وعرفت التفاصيل وكل حاجة بس بعد ما دخلت بعد ما دخلت الإنترب ما ما اشتريته
Learner B1: وخفت إني ألاقي المهندس أحمد منصور هو اللي بيعلمني التذكرة وهو اللي بيشرحلي.
Learner B3: يا جماعة أنا جربت كويس. أنا كنت عارفين أنا كنت فاكرة أصلا ده إنت دخلت.
Learner B1: حولكم.
Learner B3: والله العظيم عادي عجبني.
Learner B1: مش فاهم يعني.
Learner B3: لا، أنا ما كنتش عارفة إن الإنترنت عارفة إن إحنا بالستايل ده خالص.
Learner B1: إمم.
Learner B3: فأنا لما دخلت في الأول فتح لي تقريبا فترة معينة، فأنا قلت إن ديكرت دي بس فكنت أذاكر على أساس الغلط تماما يعني
Learner B3: طلبت
Learner B3: فهي فكرة إن إحنا نسأل بعض مش إن إحنا ناخد دي فيو على قد ده ما بخلينا كريتيف أكتر أو نفتح دماغنا أكتر
Learner B3: فاهمة يا زينب بس هيدي بس البوينت.
Learner B7: خلاص إستدركتني وخلاص إسأليني عايزة أرد عليك.
Learner B1: أنا مستعد.
Learner B3: ما.
Learner B1: في.
Learner B7: من لا مش عايزة.
Learner B3: ما تقوليش يعني أنا بقول.
Learner B7: هو في حاجة أصلا. ما يبقاش عادي جدا والله بجدل أنا كنت بغزر مش أكتر.
Learner B1: أي.
Learner B3: ده من أصغر يعني.
Learner B1: ما فيش أي حاجة بس هو.
Learner B3: الفكرة.
Learner B1: جد والله من فكرة للبنت يعني اللي حصلي خلاني إن أنا أرجع بقرار إن أنا أشتري ده.
Learner B3: أم ممكن.
Learner B1: مثل إيش.
Learner B7: جوا تيم وكلنا كلنا أوف لاين أكتر بصراحة، ما قريتش حتى كانوا ذاكرين بالفيديو. بتاعتهم إنها أونلاين
Learner B7: انترنت. ما كنتش سامعاها أصلا. غير في الآخر خالص يعني كنت متوقعة ان احنا نكون تيم وشغالين على بروجكت وكده
Learner B7: وكمان هيكون مثلا في شخص ذو خبرة قاعد بيوجهنا وكدا مش مثلا أو كذا
Learner B7: وبصراحة، توقعت مثلا بروجكت كامل هنشتغل عليه مثلا وكده
Learner B7: هو بصي على فكرة هو شبه الموجود دلوقتي عادي بس الفكرة النظام نفسه ماشي ازاي يعني حاجة لو في حاجة هيومن أكتر حتبقى مفيدة أكتر طبعا.
Learner B3: أنا فهماكي. أنا بالنسبة لي على فكرة بستفيد بفيد باك بتاع ده بالنسبة لي ده اللي أنا بعتمد عليه حاسة دي أكتر حاجة مفيدة.
Learner B1: بالظبط بالظبط على حاجة حتى مش بكون فيدباك عن اللي أنا عملتو
Learner B1: كان عندنا مشاكل في حملة على قد ما هو بيطلع معلومات وبيطلع كلام مثل أفكار بنطلع بتكنيك تمام كل حاجة تحفة.
Learner B7: فمش قادرة. أفهم.
Learner B1: يوم الأحد ده بيبقى البلاني ماشي المترو ده اللي بكون يوم الخميس اللي بيحصل فيه مشاكل معانا أول مرة.
Learner B7: أيوة بس ده اللي هو محدش دخل معانا فيه.
Learner B1: لا أول مرة خالص دخل بس مهندس إيه أحمد منصور
Learner B1: وقال معلش حصلت ظروف لقاش مهندس احمد من.
Learner B3: أحمد يوسف.
Learner B7: مرزوق بقى.
Learner B1: معلش أول 1 اللي هو أول دخل معنا أحمد منصور أحمد يوسف.
Learner B7: مش بقى.
Learner B1: أحمد يوسف.
Learner B7: تمام ده اللي كان فاتح ايس كريم كده كان فيها شوية نوتس كده بياخدها مكرحة فينا.
Learner B1: بالضبط.
Learner B7: طيب أنا مش فاهمة ممكن يا ريم تعرفيني ده كان مفيد بالنسبة لك في
Learner B3: الفيد باك.
Learner B7: أيوة فيدباك. انتي بتقوليه عن نفسك مش بتقوليها مش حد بيقولهالك عن حاجة.
Learner B3: لا معلش فيدباك اللي أنا بقوله عن نفسي.
Learner B7: أيوة. هو هو كان بيسألنا عن نفسنا.
Learner B3: إلا أنا مش فاكرة.
Learner B1: إيه لما دخلتي الرتر كان مع مين.
Learner B3: هو كان أول أسبوع كان أحمد يوسف
Learner B3: وأول مرة كان أو آخر مرتين كان مع أحمد مرزوق.
Learner B7: مرتين إحنا كمان عملنا مرة.
Learner B1: إيمر.
Learner B3: أو مرة أو
Learner B1: من.
Learner B3: مرة معي ومرة مع أحمد مرزوق.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B7: ممكن عرفت مين كان بيفيدك في إيه.
Learner B3: أنا بالنسبة لي عامة لما بتيجي من من هيومن يعني بالنسبة لي هي فكرة أكثر من أي حاجة يعني بتوجهك فعلا إن إنت مش فكرة إن حد يقول يعمل إيه بالخطوات على قد ما حد يقول لي أنا ماشية صح غلط طب الفكر ده طب مش عارفة إيه وده المفيد بالنسبة لي أهم من أي حاجة،
Learner B3: فأنا بالنسبة لي مثلا أنا لو أخدت مثلا سكور مش حلو أوي ده بالنسبة لي، أنا خدت سكور مش حلو أوي مع الأونت بس مثلا كان الفيد باك
Learner B3: حلو كده من هيومن وكده أنا بالنسبة لي أنا بعتمد أكتر.
Learner B3: بس أنا ستل شايفة إن الإي آي يعني.
Learner B7: إنت قصدك الفيد باك اللي بتاخديه من شخص.
Learner B3: من هي ومن كفكر وكده مش بس كسكور بس التلسكور كويس طبعا وبيواجهك وكل كلامك.
Learner B7: لأ البيت اللي كنا منقولها دي كنا أصلا عن عن تجربتنا.
Learner B3: لأ أنا قصدي فيدباك اللي بتقلي مش اللي أنا بقوله.
Learner B1: قلنا ما حدش يكلمنا.
Learner B3: أيوه، أسعد.
Learner B7: أيوة. أنا فاكرة في وقتها ساعتها على فكرة وقتها قالي عادل إن إنت شخص ديتيلد أورينتيد حاجة كده وقلي نادى إن هي شخص كويس في الكوميونيكيشن وبعدين كلينتون إن أنا في المقام. أنا فاكر هو فعلا مدنيش فيدباك. أنا دلوقتي عمالة الجامعة دلوقتي ما أخدتش فيدباك.
Learner B3: أنا.
Learner B1: نعم.
Learner B3: جاز.
Learner B1: ومعناها.
Learner B7: مركز فعلا مع ندى معادل أكتر. أنا افتكرت.
Learner B3: ده برضه لو قصدك على أحمد يوسف أنا كنت دخلت في الأول بس كانوا من شاري برودكت وكده بعدين طلعت شوية ورجعت ثاني فمش عارفة.
Learner B1: معلش إنت البنك الأول بتاع كانت إيه جاي منين.
Learner B3: درست إيه يعني كمبيوتر سايم الإسمنت.
Learner B1: جماد
Learner B3: أريد كتم بحرية.
Learner B1: أوه، رحت تداوي.
Learner B3: سيداوي
Learner B1: لا إله إلا الله.
Learner B3: كمان الأكاديمية.
Learner B1: لا مامبوريس.
Learner B1: الحمد لله الحمد لله.
Learner B3: طب إيه الدنيا
Learner B1: إنت متخرجة ولا مش متخرجة ولا فين.
Learner B3: لا لا تخرجت إنت.
Learner B1: أنا متخرج 20 ودخلت الجيش وخلصت الجيش واشتغلت كم سنة وتفسحت.
Learner B3: طب حلو حلو.
Learner B1: إنت مخلصة من إيمتى.
Learner B3: 24.
Learner B1: إحنا ب 26 اليمين.
Learner B3: طب وإنت ليه ما ليه حبيت.
Learner B7: هو أشير في.
Learner B1: لي.
Learner B7: بقول الأساس قوي في اي اس اعتقد يعني اروح مجال ليهم.
Learner B1: بصي هو الفكرة. إن بيو اس هو فعلا أساس قوي هو بيو اس هو ماكس ما بين الكودينغ والبروج و البزنس
Learner B1: ودي حاجة عجبه في برودكت أونر
Learner B1: هو فكرة وبنفس الوقت مع ال بيزنس تيم تمام.
Learner B3: أيوة.
Learner B3: لا أقول أنا عامة بحب قوي الحاجات اللي تربط ما بين حاجتين كده.
Learner B1: بالضبط ده اللي كان عاجبني بنفس الوقت أنا كنت معجب بفكرة بس بنفس الوقت مش عايز أكتب أنا مش أنا مش عايز أكتب شكرا بس.
Learner B7: طيب الحاجات اللي اشتغلتوا فيها تفيدكو في المجال دا.
Learner B1: لا تاني معلش السؤال.
Learner B7: الحاجات اللي اشتغلتوا فيها بعد ما اتخرجتوا فاتكوا في المجال اللي انتوا شغالين فيه ده ولا بعيدة.
Learner B1: بصي
Learner B1: مش حقولك إنك أخدتي كل حاجة في المجال ك كبيرة بتدرسي كده قصور لكل حاجة يعني تاخدي ناخدي حاجة تبع الستيك.
Learner B7: وبعد التخرج.
Learner B1: ما التخرج وتنقي حاجات بقى تساعدك؟ لا نقصد.
Learner B7: لما تدخلوا إنتشار دي إنتو جايين من حاجة أو اشتغلتوا في حاجات تفيدكو أصلا كشغل في المجال ده أصلا إنتو شفتو ليه بسهولة ولا ولا يعتبر شفت تماما.
Learner B1: ما هو أنا اشتغلت ده يعني أنا ودي مش مش بعيدة عن المجال لأ هو هو الاثنين يعتبروا هو برودكت مانجر يعني برودكت مانجر هو هو بس أكبر.
Learner B7: إنت يا مريم.
Learner B3: أنا برضه كنت وحاسة يعني أنا عامة بحس كومبيوتر سينس مش عارفة. أنا الوحيدة لأ كده ولا لأ بس بحس هو بيفرق شوية في طريقة التفكير يعني
Learner B3: فبحيس بشكل عام بتفرق وحيث مهم قوي أصلا في برودكت مانجمنت يعني
Learner B3: هو إنت تدرسي إيه ولا تخرجتي.
Learner B7: لا ما اتخرجت. قررت التالتة جامعة من يومين.
Learner B3: نايف.
Learner B7: إدارة أعمال ليست خاصة بالبنادق.
Learner B3: هلا.
Learner B1: انت منينو.
Learner B7: منين ازاي.
Learner B1: القاهرة.
Learner B7: لاء شوكولا.
Learner B1: والكلية.
Learner B1: الكلية.
Learner B7: قصدك إسم الجامعة.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: أنا جابت أزهر.
Learner B1: أهلا وسهلا بك.
Learner B3: حاسة إن إنتي حابة تشتغلي أونلاين بعد كده ولا حابة فيزكل.
Learner B7: حابة يكون مش أون لاين من البداية.
Learner B3: أم أي.
Learner B7: ومع الوقت كمان ما يكملش ممكن يبقى ميكس ده اللوبي.
Learner B3: حصل حلو أوي الموضوع.
Learner B7: يبقى لذيذ برضه اللي هو.
Learner B1: على فكرة الأونلاين مميت بجد.
Learner B7: أيوا ولو بأثر على طاقتك انت.
Learner B1: أي.
Learner B7: وفي نفس الوقت، الفول تايم كل يوم أون سايد ده حاجة برضه مميتة يعني النص حلو.
Learner B1: فرنش.
Learner B7: شايفين يا جماعة بجدل ما انتو قلتوا دراستكوا ده حاجة حمستني أكتر
Learner B7: إننا كنت بحس إن أنا أكتر 1 أكثر شخص مش مش يعني مش فاهم قوي في في فده حاجة حمستني إنتو أقنعتوني. إنه إنتو شغالين بقلكم. فترة ألريدي.
Learner B1: لا.
Learner B7: لأن أصلا ممكن طلبة جامعة عادي رغم إنتو أكيد صغيرين برضه أكيد كلكم 24 25 بالكتير بس.
Learner B1: لو سمحت.
Learner B7: أيا كان 21 فالله هو
Learner B7: هل هو برضه إيه حسستني إن إنتو لأكو مثلا متخرجين من شهر ن ده بس اللي اعتبرتها إن هي شخص عندها خبرة وكدا
Learner B7: فده يعني قلل الحماسي شوية إن أنا أكثر شخص شرف ينتج أوي فلما عرفت دي حاجة التوتر عندي بصراحة.
Learner B1: لا ما نحسبهاش كدا خالص هو عادي مش عشان إنت عميل يعني فلا هو الموضوع بالعكس ده على فكرة برودكت
Learner B1: بنسبة كبيرة. انتي تكملي حاجات في البزنس كبيرة يعني مش صغيرة
Learner B1: وعلى فكرة في ناس بيتخرجوا من كليات مش إدارة أعمال ولا كومبيوتر وبيشتغلوا و.
Learner B7: لا، لا، أنا مش قصدي كده مش قصدي على طبيعة دراستي. أنا أقصد إن كانت في فرصة إنتو تشتغلوا
Learner B7: كناس اشتغلت بإيدها
Learner B7: وإن هم في الآخر إسمهم شخص هو إمبريين مطلوب منه توصيات معينة في الآخر هو سليم وعارف يبقى شاطر فيها لأنه كان بياخد مرتب عليها هو قعد مثلا سنتين شغال فاهمني مش شخص لسه بدء حياته كإنترنت. أصلا فهمني إنت جاي من شخص. أنت ألريدي إشتغلت فترة.
Learner B7: أنا مش قصدي على نفسها. أقصد، على إن إنت إشتغلت
Learner B7: أنا عمري في تلاتين كملوا يا جماعة كمل مش قاطعكوت تاني.
Learner B3: لا، لا قولي لا لا قولي و
Learner B7: بولي والله العظيم لا تقول والله ما أصدق.
Learner B3: أم.
Learner B7: أنا.
Learner B3: لا كنت أقولك بس أنا فاهمة فاهمة إنتي بتقولي إيه يعني إن إنتي بس تحسبيها إن إنتي لسه ما تخرجتيش وكده
Learner B3: فحاسه لا وعلى فكرة حلوة قوي إن إنتي بتاخدي إنترنت كتيرة في الجماعة.
Learner B3: أنا مش عارفة إنتي حتحبي تكملي في التراكت دا ولا لأ بس لو كملتيه حاولي بقى آخر سنة إن إنتي تشتغلي بقى على بروجكتس حقيقية وتربطيه بمجالك وكده.
Learner B7: إن شاء الله.
Learner B3: حضرتك قريبة الصندوق يعني أنا بعد.
Learner B1: عندك نظامها
Learner B7: رحت مرة واحدة بس في آي تريبل وكانت أسوء تجربة في حياتي كنت حاسة إنها مش حاجة بتعلم بصراحة يعني كنت حاسة لو في كنت حاسة لو في حاجة معينة بتخدم سوفت بشكل أساسي أنها تتعلم ده بشكل أساسي كان يكون أفضل بكثير من كان بالنسبة لي سينتي ده حاجة
Learner B7: بتنفع أكتر لشخص يصنف كشخص يعني إنطوائي شوية فعايز يكسر ده بحتة شوية في الجامعة
Learner B7: يمكن تجربتي كانت وحشة أو المكان اللي كنت فيه ما اشتغلتش على بروجكت قوي
Learner B7: بس هو مناسب لشخص مش اجتماعي قوي لو شخص إجتماعي بنسبة كويسة فهو محتاج حاجة أحسن من كده من نوع يكون في اما انا بقى تجربتي كانت مع سبيسون مش ألطة في حاجة فمش عايز أعمم الموضوع برضو.
Learner B1: بصي نصيحتي ليكي يعني إنت كحد في الكلية يعني يتحفركي بقى على كتير تمام
Learner B1: بس الحاجة دي هي اللي هنغرق فيها.
Learner B3: من.
Learner B1: تمام فيعني إنتي الثالثة ماشي رابعة غرقي نفسك بقى في الحاجة دي
Learner B1: يعني يعني أنا عارف مين مش بيكون سهلا لأن
Learner B1: موجودة يعني بس ساعات لو ربنا كرم يعني وفقك ممكن تلاقي بس أقولك الأسهل يعني عمي بقى.
Learner B7: إلى اللقاء.
Learner B1: أم.
Learner B7: فعلا المشاكل الوحيدة.
Learner B3: ليوم.
Learner B7: ما تعرفوني شوي طبسطو كده بصراحة.
Learner B3: يا رب.
Learner B7: كمية.
Learner B3: اشتغلت.
Learner B7: أكيد.
Learner B3: على ماني بروتوفولي وكده و
Learner B3: عشان بصراحة ما أكذبش عليكي هو سوق العمل صعب فإنتي لسه في الجامعة. إنت عندك أنت
Learner B3: فيعني ركزي آخر سنة دي أنا عارفة إن هو مشروع تخرج مش تبقي فايق قوي بس عشان كده بقولك حاولي إن إنت تعملي جنبه ولو حاجات بسيطة تعملي بها بروتوفولي.
Learner B7: مش عندي مشروع تخرج الحمد لله.
Learner B3: طب حلو يبقى إنت قدامك سنة كاملة حرفيا إنت عندك بحر سنة. فإنت تستغليها.
Learner B1: هو.
Learner B3: كويس قوي.
Learner B7: إن أنا ضيعت تلات سنين كنت واجه الذاتي. إن سنة واحدة مش حعمل فيها الهواء.
Learner B1: إنت إنت طالما مش عندك مشروع تخرج إنت إعملي مشروع
Learner B1: عشان إنت لما تخشي في هتخشي إنترفيو حيسألك إنت عملتي طيب عاملة بورتوبوليو في كذا وكذا وكذا
Learner B1: لو إيه حد يعني تبقي بتكلمي في حاجة.
Learner B7: أه.
Learner B3: ولو عرفتي تشتغلي برضه مثلا أو مع حتى لو حاجة بسيطة أو مثلا تبعتي لشركات صغيرة أو كده هتبقى بجد حلوة قوي يعني حاولي تشتغلي مع عملاء حقيقيين
Learner B3: ولأ ما.
Learner B7: هو دلوقتي.
Learner B3: ده مش قليل.
Learner B7: دلوقتي مولدة.
Learner B7: أنا دلوقتي اللي هو الجماعة في مثلا اللي هو في اللي هو ال دي اف اللي هو تعرفه سامعني.
Learner B3: 87.
Learner B7: ده أنا فيني دلوقتي فأنا لسه مش عارفة حجم الحاجة اللي ممكن يشتغلوا عليها فحاسة إن هو ممكن يفيد شوية
Learner B7: ان شاء الله بقى أعرف أعمل في حاجة.
Learner B3: وبحس يعني إن إنتي تحاولي تربطي الحاجات ده بعض يعني حاولي تفكري برا الصندوق يعني وأقول لك يعني إن شاء الله.
Learner B7: شكرا جدا.
Learner B3: مع كريم.
Learner B1: الدائنينو يعني قبل ما نخلص من موضوع تمام.
Learner B7: تمام.
Learner B3: إن شاء الله.
Learner B1: الله.
Learner B3: أوكي يلا
Learner B3: باي باي.